Four
three,
two,
one.
And we're live Mr. Roth as live,
as live will ever possibly get on the intergrade international.
Good to see you man.
You really do look great.
You look healthy,
you look vibrant.
You look surprised.
No surprise.
You know,
I've,
I haven't been to sleep since the late eighties.
I didn't miss a thing,
but I'm a little groggy,
but I'm good to go in my job.
You expect Desta dissipation and illness rights,
you know,
kind of goes along with you.
You expect a disintegration in my kind of job and Lemmy from Motorhead style.
Um,
do you know the term Wabisabi do you know what that is?
No.
Wabisabi he's Japanese term.
That succinctly put means that which is perfect cause it's a little fucked up.
Uh,
your favorite jeans very well.
The a Patina on an old car.
The Guitar player in the rolling stones.
Very,
oh,
of us up.
Yes.
He's very Wasabi.
Yeah.
In New York City for example,
the old that starts to fall apart right next to the new,
that's part of the beauty.
They're your favorite leather jacket.
Is that,
can you expect that to increase?
But,
uh,
I dunno,
I'm not really an athlete.
I don't really train 'em kind of a singer who always traded his celebrity to,
you know,
hey,
show me how you do that and how many times should I lift this?
And,
uh,
what happens if I fall off of this going this fast?
But you used to train,
right?
You used to,
didn't you train with Benny or Kitezh oh yeah.
I went through a martial arts the first time.
Um,
let me go back.
Okay.
I lived in student housing up until I was just about a teenager.
And it was a time when you bought one paint brush at a time.
Okay.
And most of my values come from that public library.
I learned to swim at a public swimming pool and my dad finished medical school.
Okay.
I happened,
I wasn't planned in the 50s that happened a lot.
And uh,
so we had a lot,
a lot of patients who were kind of on the periphery of Pasadena,
California,
which is where we came.
Okay.
I was born in Indiana,
lived in Massachusetts.
He was a resident grow up around the hospitals.
Dinner meant going to the hospital,
meet Dad,
and when we came out to la,
the Japanese were kind of peripheral Spanish speaking people.
Curiously enough,
you know the running story was that there were six Spanish speaking people at
Ucla and three of them were in gardening.
No,
really?
That went back in the 60s that was the case today.
Easily,
you know,
massive amounts of percentages.
A Uab most officiant is Tom.
He okay.
It's not a second language.
It's kind of the first in half now.
Things have really changed a mental and grew up in those neighborhoods.
Okay.
So I can gang sign the whole alphabet.
Can you really?
Yeah.
I have two low riders.
I've got a really,
well I got a 51 mercury that's Jap.
Drop low and slow.
Do you drive it?
Oh yeah.
I got a 66 v Dub bug with a Chevy engine.
A three 83 up in the front or Denali is he and I couldn't.
Oh my gosh,
you gotta roll.
Your rs is the whole Allie,
what did he drive those things?
No,
we drive them all around,
you know,
it's,
it's southern California of course is different.
A lot of you are listening in with five layers and gone,
hey fuck,
I'm not driving anywhere for the next three days according to the weather map,
you know.
But uh,
here for example,
it's tee shirt,
weather.
So you know,
the great outdoors means,
how's that sound over the headphones?
It sounds like an engine.
Yup.
Yeah.
But I always treat the first time I ever,
we were just playing with a sword there.
And that's not a summarized story.
That's like calling a nine millimeter a police gun.
Yeah,
it kind of is because they used,
but that's a Katon Huh?
Right.
And we were playing with that a little bit.
First Time somebody handed me those,
we were at the Buddhist temple in Pasadena 19.
You Bet.
I remember 1965 and there was a demonstration of the Japanese culture.
Thank you.
And a fella came out and demonstrated,
I thought,
oh,
and you know,
there's of arts and stuff.
And then he,
she said,
I'm going to take somebody from the audience.
And my dad pushed me and I walked out in the middle of that floor and held it
here.
Hold that sort.
It just like you said,
wow.
That's what does that 100 year olds or 15 hundreds years whammo mood maci or
something like this.
First Time I held that story,
it was like out of a graphic novel,
lightning.
And as a ma,
that's Japanese for lightening.
Careful what you show your kids.
Joe,
you went and lived in like last time I talked to you,
you were living in Japan who are doing Kendo over there.
Yes.
Uh,
well you pitch up awesome.
Dan.
I'm going to play for the Yankees.
Joe.
I love the Uracil and grapple and someday I'm going to get in the middle of the
ring and Joe Rogan's going to saint my name
and I'm working my way up through Ed Parker's American Kampo system and someday
I'm going to Jay Payne.
Fine.
I'm going to learn from the guys who invented this stuff.
Now I'm putting on a pork barrel,
acts it to make it entertaining.
But it did.
And I started exactly like I did.
You know,
Barham Boulevard making rock and roll with the Mighty v Mighty van Halen in the
late seventies,
uh,
at the Oakwood Garden apartment in midtown Tokyo.
I did not know a single person.
I didn't know a syllable of Japanese.
I had no idea where I was and no,
I can't drive on the left side of the street.
I barely carry a cell phone.
Karen,
come on.
And uh,
uh,
I suspect that a lifetime of adventure you do all the traveling come on artists
to artists,
your home everywhere now,
aren't you?
Yeah.
And a lot of ways you are the comfortable one in the room,
especially if there's conflict,
which there always is.
And that's what's the most unsettling to the,
to the tourists.
Travelers,
you're at home when you first start learning Japanese comes in three stages.
First you watch kids shows on television because they pronounce everything and
nobody interrupts.
Then you watched the news.
Everybody speaks with a perfect accent,
bigger words,
nobody interrupts.
And then you start going with me to the movies in the middle of the day on
Tuesday and Tokyo,
it Ginza and you're the only pale face in the room.
It's all in Japanese and it's the movies.
Everybody's interrupting,
everybody's shooting,
screaming,
sirens,
airplanes going by,
and if you can begin to decipher even one character,
then you'll develop yours.
Maybe.
Why do you know how to write it while you practice that?
Certainly,
and think of it is cross training.
All right?
There are a lot of schools,
for example,
a Hebrew school,
you always hear about Hebrew school before you go to bar Mitzvah class.
It's an ancient way of,
wait a minute.
You got to develop the side of your brain by correlating designs with language,
with meaning that may not actually be in English.
Nobody's walking around speaking Hebrew after all the only four summers of why,
but you develop that side of your brain to where you start to have a capacity to
learn in an accelerated way.
So all your best musicians speak a couple languages.
We are best politicians.
Speak a couple of all your best artists,
architects,
all your best,
uh,
design folks and still speak a couple of language.
It's no secret that you develop that side of your brain.
If your kids don't speak Spanish,
get after it.
I had to learn a language that's the,
it's never too late.
You'll see the difference.
You don't,
I did every single day,
every of,
I called it Roth University in Tokyo every morning for two hours.
Japanese class.
You know,
speaking the language.
I can get things done for you,
but I'm not conversant.
You follow?
Uh,
the end result is that it's cross training.
Alright.
Longterm memory.
My short term memory is a little too short and getting shorter,
but you'll see the difference in your ability to remember what you read.
They'll start remembering everything you see sometimes as dangerous because of
the fact that you're learning this new thing.
So you're activating this part of your brain.
Oh yeah.
You'll start it off with little kids in art class for example,
where you take a pencil and you got this just a pencil.
But what else could it be?
Well in this environment is a stick shift.
Pla.
No,
it's not.
It's a Kubo ton.
He's got Joe's risk.
No,
I'm a little girls go.
It's a bode dad.
Me,
I'm a hero also end of the day.
And you can start to think in those terms using actual language movement.
Same thing.
At this point in your career with Jujitsu and grappling,
you have a vocabulary that starts to expand,
expand by having to learn and challenge and challenge
people.
Marvel at Anthony Bordain gun blessing.
Uh,
one is biggest talent was to be at home everywhere.
No matter what somebody might say or a posture or present,
he was able to let it go by when later or no,
we'll Duke it out right here.
And he had the capacity to stay cool in the middle of all of it.
So maybe it's stay cool school when you think,
well,
he just had a fascinating mind for travel and food and culture and he just
wanted to know everything about how these people thought about the world and saw
things differently.
And if I feel,
I kind of feel bad now for people that don't travel,
I really do.
It's just,
I feel like you're missing so much of what a human being is.
Travel is a little bit perhaps like music or looking at art on the wall.
You kind of have to have somebody teach you how to do it a little bit.
Like the fight game.
He,
Oh,
you know,
you could,
somebody could sit with you and,
and get really bored with technical boxing and it might be the best you've ever
seen.
And it's not a slug faster or Braun,
you have to explain,
well,
see some jazz,
some jazz bitches,
brew Conor Mcgregor's bitches brew arguably one of the smell several.
It's all over the place and lists and some is very contained.
Look,
the disc jockeys voice.
Yeah,
we've a very mechanized,
the jazz thing is a really good analogy because you're either into jazz,
are you not into jazz?
And I,
I've never,
I liked electronics background music,
but I have a good friend.
My friend Alonzo Boden is a jazz efficient natto and he like host jazz tours and
stuff.
And he's a standup comic,
so he'll do like comedy on these things and he just loves it.
I mean,
he like lives for it.
Well I,
she look on your face just because nobody taught you how to taste beer.
Beer works in three parts and like it says in the Pickwick papers,
you don't taste it with a sep wait.
Tastes.
Yeah.
Gotta go.
You gotta go off.
You gotta hit something.
And when you describe,
well there's the finish to the taste of a Cuban cigar.
They go,
you mean when it's finished in the APP?
No,
the finish.
Okay.
Somebody explain these things to me.
All right.
What's the difference between Scotch whiskey and Tennessee Bourbon?
Well,
there's an e in the word and Bourbon whiskey.
There's an e in,
there is no e in the,
in whiskey for
Scotch.
Okay.
That simple sort of starts it jazz music.
Somebody explains it to you in very simple,
digestible,
now lofty necktie terms,
you begin to understand a little bit of what's going on.
How do you,
how do you explain it to them?
Okay.
How would you explain jazz?
I'm gonna,
I'll really tighten up for you.
Um,
excuse me.
Wow.
At least I got my health.
Go for me.
Um,
we'll do it in the Beatles style.
Here's the best way to go for somebody new and interested the McCartney note and
that Lennon note.
Okay.
The McCartney node is always kind of happy.
I've actually bumped into Sir Paul over at Henson Studios and he's really happy.
Okay.
And here's now note we go,
Nah,
Nah.
Here.
How pretty that sounds.
Sounds pretty.
I'll do it again.
Bad Ass Lennon.
He's the salt and the caramel baby.
He's got,
there's a darkness.
There's an edge.
There's a shadow.
Listen to the last three notes.
Ah,
AH,
and there's a little darkness.
It,
both of those last three notes is where you'd get that little,
just a little bit of pepper in the chocolate,
yo.
Ah,
uh,
and it's a little wistful,
is a little melancholy.
And he lifelike that.
And when you put them together,
it doesn't sound like they do.
But if I could,
I'd sing both parts in,
it goes together and you go,
wow.
Bittersweet.
Like my fucking career.
Like my last three [inaudible] and there we go.
So you kind of have to listen to jazz like you would taste wine k the best for
this felonious monk,
you know,
same thing.
The right hand is Paul left his job and he's working these days.
You can't tell is it happy or sad?
I Dunno.
How was dinner last night?
Same.
We get it.
It is a indicative if that's what's around you cause snatches tappy that's
Disney snatches.
Sad.
You know,
think of something.
Somebody who's always tuning his guitar to sad.
There are some folks who,
Leonard Cohen,
who since passed as well,
that sounded more like Bowie,
but I don't know what you mean.
Getting Tattoos.
Two sleeves.
Yeah,
both of my arms.
Same here.
I rarely show.
Okay.
Then maybe that's a baby boomer thing from the elbow up.
Yeah.
I'm a,
I have this all Japanese style,
right?
Traditional tap style.
Did you have all my colors were tapped in and in front is Horiyoshi I have the
Tuxedo.
Damn you do?
Yeah.
The whole butt cheeks and everything.
Yeah,
the whole thing.
The interpreter had to sit on me and hold me down.
I'm not going to kid you.
It was a trial.
You know what I imagined.
Is it much more painful to do at that top way?
No,
it should.
Overall,
I think what happens is tattoo,
when you get something that stings,
you can take it for a while.
It's the distance that counts.
It can take the cold for 30 seconds.
You can take a measurable cold.
Are you doing the Cryo Dunk?
Okay,
boom.
You can take anything for 30 seconds.
You're in show Biz,
but man trial and that out in front of you for 15 seconds.
Kind of a that your suit.
Yeah.
Wow.
Look at that.
So there's some photos of it up.
Yeah,
because you never really do a show your tattoos anywhere.
That's not part of the show.
It's not part of,
but behind the scenes,
my mom,
who was an art teacher was the,
the,
the healing happy side of my family came from my dad.
I learned a box from mom.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Bad Dave.
Like my sisters call it comes from civil Roth.
Okay.
If you,
if you ha you competed for the magnet for the refrigerator.
Okay.
And Mom would be doing something and you'd come up with your new drawing and
she'd say,
should I go get the magnet and not look at it?
Wow.
And you wouldn't look and go,
you're right.
Stay here.
Yes.
Harsh.
Yeah.
And then before you would look at it,
go clean up your paint box.
We shear brushes.
Okay.
Ah,
we're on family.
And when I got my Tuxedo,
first thing mom shed was I really liked the colors.
What do you do when you're outdoors?
Playing Ball.
Okay.
And that's part of what compels what we're doing here.
I invented inc the original.
Okay.
And this is a whole series of things that didn't exist before.
So products to protect your,
your tattoo.
Oh yeah.
You know,
I just,
whenever I go anywhere outside,
I sprayed down with sunscreen and people are like,
why are you doing that?
And I was like,
cause I don't want my tattoos to fade away.
I have artwork on my body.
You have a,
Rembrandt was probably more expensive than the paint job on your car.
Driving a ranger series for sure.
Yeah,
I'm serious.
Yeah.
And you won't think twice about it.
Okay.
Cause it's forever.
All right.
It's forever.
I'm 64 doctor says 64 is the new 90 for me.
Take my word for him a little farther down range then Aladdin.
I can tell you what I see from here.
You look great.
If you wait until you're 55 to start hitting the weight stack,
you will look like a 55 year old who trains three times a week.
Right?
If you start when you're two digits old,
you'll fool yo full.
Yeah.
And that's Canada fun.
You just gotta keep moving.
Oh yeah.
You start way early.
When did you start the tattoos?
Uh,
I got my first one in 1977.
All right.
Came back from a delirious,
a trip to the West indies.
Uh,
and a handful of folks that were camping out on the beach.
I'm a combat hippie.
Okay.
Peace,
love and heavy weapons case.
You know,
they don't want to feel the love and a camping commune style somewhere in the,
it was in Martinique and the West indies and we all came back and got a sea
horse on the,
uh,
on the ankle.
Oh boy.
How Feminine.
Yeah.
And then from there I waited,
you know,
most,
uh,
today,
what's popular,
for example,
Hispanic style,
you,
you use the badges plot,
you document something.
Here's a,
here's a name,
here's something we got when we went on spring break or something when we got
married and you build like a mural and I waited to do the whole thing in one
sweep,
you know,
thinking in terms of planning.
So I waited until,
you know,
I was well past that.
I just celebrated my 60th birthday,
but I get about 300 hours in on it and uh,
I'm still outdoors.
I'm still bouncing around and there was nothing out there.
I've been climbing.
I started off at Joshua tree and climbing out at Taco kits in the 70s.
Didn't now how I wasn't Alex Honnold just on the show here.
Okay.
Well.
Same circuit from camp four to studio 54.
I was on,
I was in both.
I was flavor of the week the first time when studio 54 was that happening?
Okay.
At the same time I had just bought a Winnebago that looked like something from a
breaking bad.
It's the same Winnebago.
I saw it as did I used to own that?
That was for nothing but going to Yosemite.
Really?
You just know how Al and the documentary is,
is living in his van?
Pardon me?
Always looks back at that.
It's wow.
Sleeping in the back of Bobby hatches,
pickup truck parked out in the middle of nowhere in Joshua Tree 1973 and you
would be climbing even back then.
Oh yeah.
What it,
what kind of equipment did you guys use back then today?
No,
not nothing like it.
We used webbing for are harnessing.
And you used a 11 millimeter Kern mantle or Manila rope.
All right.
And I remember the first time was in 1972 you'll see his name,
John Ball.
Uh,
uh,
as pioneering a lot of the routes in Joshua Tree.
First Time we watched him as seniors in highschool go flagging,
you know,
are you pressure with,
can you see this?
And the a screen there where you pull with your hands and push with your feet
will flagging all the way up the corner of a handball court at mere highschool
in Pasadena,
all the way up to the top and then stood on the top and looked down showing
incredible.
Wow.
Well nine incredible talents.
We'd never seen such a thing.
And from that point,
uh,
you know,
we just Florida because living in a,
up in Yosemite in the various parts was something new.
Traveling to Joshua tree Takut down to the beaches and such.
That was a constant for me.
I've always tried to follow some thing as opposed to thinking of his training.
Even the,
even the word training tastes like homework,
right?
So I've always tried to,
I was running for a long period of time,
about seven years when I jogged and ran and I decided on the road,
I'll run across every bridge in America that we tour through.
So I probably 1520 different bridges.
Golden Gate Brooklyn's.
That's where I rent now.
I did smoke a joint and run the New York City Marathon
and I came in right behind the wheelchairs in the back.
Okay,
well some folks need the ribbon and they need to see the clock and everybody
clapping.
And then there's some folks,
you know who just [inaudible] it did okay.
And they had took down the clock,
but the line was still there on the sea,
meant in central park,
hopped over the line,
got the picture airborne,
went home,
took a nap,
and that night I went out and got drunk on Tequila.
How long did it take you to finish the marathon?
And about five and a half hours.
That's not bad.
That's very good.
It's better than Berkshire.
Now let's come on.
Let's be complimentary.
It's the worst.
It's definitely,
yes.
That's about the absolute worst that you,
it was the winter do it our 20 I think they get it in a round two hours,
like two hours in seven.
Seventh sac is,
I think they're trying to break two hours.
Isn't that what's going on?
Someone's trying to break two hours.
So,
but that's what I did for a period of time,
you know,
keep going,
kayaking,
you know.
So you just always been involved in physical activities that were fun in the
early nineties.
Kayaking was illegal in Manhattan.
Okay.
Because it was dirty water and people would get trundled over under the ferry
boats.
Oh God.
So what we did is we cut a hole in the fence next to the 14th street sanitation
department over by the,
uh,
west side highway.
Y'All know what I'm talking about?
If you're from there.
And we did it exactly like movie style,
like a great escape where we fitted the fence back with duck tape and we would
drag our kayaks from union square west all the way down 14th street.
Okay.
And you pick up your provisions for it.
All right?
You got to get your bagels,
she got to get shit done.
But you know,
like this,
you got to get something to drink,
get some Gatorade,
you know,
not to drink the gate array so you have something to Wiz in serious.
And um,
we'd get the girlfriends okay.
To wait up is in the meatpacking district right there.
It's dead silent.
It was a ghost town.
Then there was not hip hop.
It was not going,
which is what it's doing now.
And he'd go to shopping with your old lady had said Stella Mccartney down there
now at Benton is a ghost town.
It was crazy,
scary,
dangerous.
And one girlfriend,
which I gotta be careful of names.
They're all married now.
How'd you manage it?
The mine,
Karen
would always go north and wait around because if the cops come,
they would step out.
We would see them or whatever and we would sneak our bolts through the hole in
the fence into the river,
right where solely landed his plane,
uh,
right there.
All right.
And,
and girls would come and jump in a boat and we would take off more than two or
three times.
Local PD would show going,
hey,
what do,
what?
Are you going to touch that water back then?
No,
that was,
that was death.
Inky black horror death.
Did you ever Dunkin it accident?
No,
not in,
not in that river particular,
but we started a number of the trips today.
You,
there's probably six different kayak clubs that you can jump.
Manhattan,
Kayak Club and Brooklyn,
many,
many now the boomers.
What senses of humor figured it all out.
All right.
And we would go,
Geez,
we started trips.
We'd go at midnight under the Verrazano Bridge in the winter.
All right.
And you were dry suits or something.
You know,
you're a long,
long Johns inside of a dry sheet like this.
And don't get me wrong,
I would be the DJ,
I have a,
um,
a,
a tape player and I would bungee to take player like this and everybody would
have,
this is a primitive times,
you know,
it's 19,
early nineties.
You know,
I just,
and we would have a little microphones in the earpieces that you use on
motorcycles back then.
So you have communications from boat to boat.
Oh Wow.
And I would put mine on the tape player and I'd be the Tj.
Oh yeah.
And we'd listen to the ballgame late at night sometimes you know,
and you hear laughing all,
you couldn't see anybody in the swells and we'd go under the same bridge that
John Travolta sits and looks at with the girlfriend in Saturday.
Night fever,
same bridge,
you know that a woody Allen in Manhattan,
it looks,
you know,
you have a wonderful us on the other side is terrible imitation of either of
them and we'd float under their full moon,
midnight February,
snow drifting like this.
And since it was illegal to do it,
we had a buddy who owned a plumbing company in Brooklyn and he would bring his
truck and park it right off a Coney island.
You're still well avenue where the Ferris wheel is and he would blink his
lights,
allied forces style blink,
blink like that.
And we'd be about a quarter mile off having come from under the Verrazano
Bridge.
And whenever we'd see those lights blink,
nowhere to turn left.
He started,
do you even want to hear this?
Yes.
Okay.
We'd have to make the left and we'd wait for the swells.
Like,
can you give us another blank?
When all was clear and jazz,
beat ass all a quarter mile of row,
row,
catch the wave,
get out of the boat and everyone,
you know,
silently drag it all the way up the beach.
Okay.
Like you see in every war movie.
All right.
Otherwise just smashed it,
I don't know,
$200 fine or something like this.
And we would put the boats big two person kayaks into the back of the plumbing
truck and onto the top of it,
drive it back to the coffee shop on Union Square West.
It's very well known like that and get drunk with pretty girls and tell them
about adventure stories.
And all this was going on while you were,
you were air quotes David Lee Roth.
I mean,
this is the nineties.
You were fucking huge.
You're still a rockstar and you're going through polluted water in a fucking
Kayak.
Hide him from the cops,
but a tape player and uh,
and uh,
some sort of jury rigged,
uh,
microphones.
So some of the best places that I went rock climbing.
Uh,
we're on walls of hotels in Europe.
We'd toss,
toss a rope out the third floor of a bed and breakfast in San Sebastian,
Spain.
That's covered from flagstone with flagstone from the 14 hundreds like that.
And then Yo,
Yo,
you know,
one guy would stay up,
watch TV and work the belay and you can climb up the outside,
you know,
it's Jesus Christ.
Hardcore jollies send you were doing this all around the same time?
Oh yeah.
My bicycles with me,
I'm going to,
it's outdoors is in the blood,
you know,
it's part of growing up without any real things.
My Dad was a student,
so,
uh,
take this stick for you.
It'll be a bow for me.
It be a baton.
When did you start working as an EMT?
That was around the same time,
wasn't it?
Emt was about 12 summers ago for me.
So I was turning 50 and I started going back to school for outdoor med response,
camping,
climbing.
And what is it like when you go to one of those classes and they realized who
you are?
How weird does it kid?
Ah,
sometimes you can get a little bit uptight because I'm the oldest guy in the
room,
right?
And I want to clarify something.
Okay.
When I became an EMT shield number three,
two seven,
four 66 47th precinct,
big shout out to all of you who taught me and tolerated me until I became an EMT
and put on that uniform.
I wasn't somebody,
somebody cleaned the fucking truck up
until I put on that uniform Gel after training for how many months?
It's almost a year for me like this.
I wasn't someone,
someone clean up the track
and that was my job starting right off.
But uh,
I was also the somebody who dragged the oxygen box all 13 floors up in the
didn't walled projection artists to artists.
How many times have you driven past something,
whether it's a huge building or at tp
wonder what's in there and then you go live with him.
I wonder which in the frigerator I wonder what they listened to in there and I
wonder who they are.
I have a fascination for that.
My pop had a big sprawling,
I think.
Is it simply empathy for people?
You know,
when the fellows started getting age in the early eighties he started treating
him.
He's an eye surgeon and everybody,
my sisters and stuff started saying,
but this is a time when you think you can catch that shift from breathing it pop
and whatever.
And he turned to me,
I'll never forget,
he said,
I don't get to choose my patients.
Yeah.
Wow.
I don't get to choose my audience.
So what was the motivation to start doing that though?
We'll see what's in there.
Where's your rater Joe?
And you'll walk in first cause you're way stronger than me in case there's
trouble and you'll go and be lunch and in case somebody comes at us you handle
it.
Oh,
I had a,
I had a mentor named Kesha who had the pile or dreadlocks up so high that it was
as long as from her shoulders to the top of her head,
her haircut,
it was like she had to,
she put her hat up on top and Kesha walk in that door.
First homie
domestic disputes.
She dealt with the guys.
You had to be there for domestics.
Yeah.
Oh,
those girls.
Gary is a very,
and you get an eye on your audience.
Stops being audience starts being the neighborhood.
Yeah,
and pretty soon you live in the neighborhood.
I was under the train once in the Fulton Street station too.
I can do a homeless,
valid quick briefing.
Act like nothing's wrong.
She and get them to come out,
hi,
you're hungry.
Train breathes.
Okay.
Subway,
Jame breeze.
It doesn't just sit there silently
and he got to go real.
Geez,
I'm laughing now,
but that's a nervous laugh.
Well and now every one of those folks is in my voice when I sing.
Oh,
I liked that.
I like that thought process.
When you decided to do this,
was this a conscience?
A conscious effort to try to just enrich your experiences.
Cross training,
cross training.
I'll give it to quick rationale and I also know it's going to change me.
Don't know how,
but she got to get in it.
And after a certain point in your life,
maybe a go where there is no shallow and challenge yourself as just design.
Move somewhere.
That's a foreign language as you can't even read the street signs.
Uh,
in Japan for example.
Um,
but you know,
you start off on the bunny slopes.
You don't surf 40 footers.
Righto.
At first you got to move to New York and go through that whole thing of what
have I done?
But what's so what's the thought process when you're like,
I'm going to be an EMT,
I'm going to study for a year,
I'm going to train,
I'm going to go out there and I'm going to actually do it.
I okay.
Sometimes when I go for a walk in the city,
my plan is just follow where the sun is beaming.
I get to an intersection,
the sun is on that far corner.
I'll cross over to that and then I'll look down the block and see where the sun
is and I walked down the block and get into that part.
And he's doing a lot of this by yourself.
Oh yeah.
I did the same thing with EMT training.
Jeez.
My Dad was a doctor.
The first and the merit badge I got as a boy scout was first date.
I was that guy and I learned that for skinny guy like me.
Real power probably came from being cool when everybody else is gone.
Yeah.
Because my dad had to do that.
I assisted him in surgeries at a very early age.
Oh yeah.
And you know and stuff that made everybody else I this pop.
Good.
I have a good ambulance voice.
You want to hear it?
Let me do that.
Okay,
hold on again.
You're going to be just fine.
Can you imagine,
you know,
being in an ambulance and look up and it's motherfucking David Lee Roth telling
you you're going to be okay.
You'd be like,
Oh,
I'm dead and wants to be dead.
I only twice has that actually happened cause I only worked in the hood.
Oh they worked around it at night.
I only worked,
she,
you know,
you would never expect to see me once was after Oz fest football stadium.
Yeah.
Some unfortunate was uh,
you know,
uh,
drank too much or whatever and he was out of sorts and you know,
sitting in a corner,
somebody phoned him in from the local liquor store and
uh,
you could see that disbelief in his face,
you know,
and I leaned over and said to him,
Hey,
you're going to be just fine.
Like this is like the lyrics of an Ozzy song come to life.
Yeah.
But beyond that,
no,
nobody ever really did.
And uh,
you know,
Jesus,
I weighed 15 more pounds.
I was doing the Arnold routine at the wage stack because I was somebody,
well,
somebody help me lift this
my fourth day.
I'm not in them.
Not a pretentious about,
you know what my fourth days work.
So you bulked up for the job?
Oh yeah.
And a,
I wait 15 more pounds and I lifted,
man,
I could lift.
I lifted people out of bathtubs.
I lifted him out of the ocean,
I lifted him out of the projects,
I lifted him out of the truck,
I lifted him into the other truck as the first truck just broke down in the
snow.
I live.
And uh,
just do this for all.
Sorry.
How long did you do this for?
I restarted once about four and a half summers.
Four and a half years.
Okay.
And I,
you know,
in between,
uh,
playing and whatever,
and again,
a big shout out to all my teachers and mentors,
not a day goes by.
I don't think about it.
And not a day goes by that,
uh,
I don't use some skill including that,
you know,
that'll level your head a little bit.
Yeah.
Somebody go make some coffee,
Joel.
So you feel like for a guy like you who was such a gigantic superstar and you
just touring these huge arenas and people were freaking out every time they see
you,
for you,
it was,
um,
maybe a good way to balance things out too because you're seeing people in a
life or death situation and dire straits when they're unhealthy and they need
help and you're out there in the down and dirty and the nitty gritty,
like,
you know,
like you said,
trucks breaking down,
picking people up out of the bathtubs.
Well,
a lot of what you just described is the first response team.
Yes.
We always describe our patients,
our friends and clients.
Okay.
But the struggle for our,
I'll call it the uniform starts with military police,
fire first response I'll throw in nursing or emergency room and those of us with
bells and whistles who she called the ambulance,
et Cetera.
Um,
you see that from the inside out.
Yeah.
And that really will sharpen your vision.
Mm.
Okay.
Um,
for example,
uh,
right off the bat,
I pay 52% in taxes,
just tear my dollar in half,
half for many,
many years.
Um,
I'm all for tripling police,
fire,
medical paramedic,
uh,
emergency nursing Satra like that starting pay should be $2,500
a week and on I'm fine.
I would pay more tax happily.
I would too if that case would be,
and we would take what is a very,
a set of very refined sciences and art forms.
Everything I just described,
I call it the uniform because we put on a uniform and we go to work in there
like that on it's time to go digital and you can start making real demands in
terms of,
uh,
just the preparation you follow,
today being on the beat,
uh,
taking care of people,
whether you're in first response medical or answering fire causes on par these
days,
you have to make the decisions of a seal team or where same training,
where's the same gear?
I went to a,
I was out in palm springs at the International School for tactical medicine out
there and the Fella's,
we've had game wardens from Alaska.
We had heavy rescue from Cleveland.
We had all manner of folks coming through there and they all discuss,
well sometimes we have to share one helmet,
what sometimes we don't have enough guys to do this and that.
So we just parked the car and let them think.
There's these kinds of stories follow and if you start paying people what
they're worth and start paying people according to what your expectations then a
lot of things,
I don't go political.
Didn't nonsense like Charlottesville in what's happening in a lot of areas are
any states we'll go by the wayside as moved from no qualifications necessary to
hey man,
you guys work just as hard and you endanger yourself way more than a trial
attorney.
Yes.
I personally got out of jury duty recently by saying,
uh,
I didn't want to get out of jury duty.
In fact,
I raised my hand when the judge says anybody here think they can do jury duty.
You're all trying to get out of it.
And I raise my hand and she said,
why?
I said,
because I now can see that there are neighborhoods where everybody is.
I know of neighborhoods where everybody's a liar,
a cheat,
a cripple.
And if they're not,
they're covering for somebody.
And she said,
what neighborhood is that?
I said,
me go community in Beverly Hills.
The fail of almost dropped his gun.
Everybody was laughing.
They dismissed me too.
Opinionated.
Mr. Roth,
you've had too much life experience.
Actually don't let the door hit you in the ass on the way out.
Yep.
Have you ever done jury duty?
No,
I have not.
If I,
uh,
if I did get in there I'd probably just tell them I think everyone's guilty.
Well,
you have cops eyes.
It's when you walk into the room and you know,
everybody's lying.
Nah,
not really.
I mean,
I,
I
probably should do it soon.
Probably be good experience for me.
Do they ask you to do it?
I'm sure it's happened.
I keep showing up.
The last time I actually showed up a fella,
uh,
I think it was a drive is two guys who were being accused of shooting.
Somebody walks up,
he's last,
I dunno,
it looks faintly Slavic.
If you grew up with James Bond
movies,
everybody will know who you are.
You are very popular in new FIDESSA.
Is the cough
kind of a thing?
Where are you playing next?
You're in Pasadena.
Yeah.
Tell me his house all the time.
Constantly there.
Do you have a vibe about the ice house?
Is there a Mojo to it?
Oh yeah,
please explain all this comedy club in the known universe that that place has
been in operation since the 1960s it was originally an actual ice house where
back before there was refrigeration.
They would bring in ice and people would go to buy ice.
They'd have a gigantic,
you know,
freezer type room was insulated,
so it keeps the ice for a long time.
Then it became like a variety type place and then somewhere in the 60s it became
a comedy club and it is now the oldest,
longest running comedy club in the world.
I was working as a janitor slash tech in surgery at a hospital,
Pasadena.
Oh,
so it was night shift.
Okay.
Wow.
They're early seventies we did everything.
It was the stepping stone to going to medical school and I was playing Acoustic
Guitar.
Can I still take lessons playing acoustic guitar.
Okay.
And on Sunday nights,
audition night,
you would sign up for audition at the ice house at six 30 they'd opened the
window and you would sign up.
So I'd take my dinner break and drive my opal cadet station wagon up to the Ice
House,
get there at about six 15 wait,
they pop the window,
sign up so that I would be one of the first three to audition after the last act
on Sunday night,
which would happen right around 10 o'clock if you weren't one of the first three
during audition night.
Nobody was there and they shut it down and I would sign up and go back to work
and then come,
you know,
drive myself back.
Change Adam I and hospital stuff,
you know,
put on the right clothes for my jeans if it ever,
and I auditioned there probably 15 times.
Wow.
Bob Stain who owned and ran the place was just a voice over the intercom and he
was unforgiving.
Bob was a famous non smiler.
What's funny is there's a Bob that owns it now,
Bob Fisher.
It couldn't be more different.
The nicest guy on the planet earth.
Always smiling,
hugging everybody.
Super Sweetheart of a guy.
Okay,
well Bob Stein was a voiceover,
the intercom.
He was hardcore,
you know,
have a,
you go,
well,
here's a little song.
And the voice would say,
hopefully it's a littler than the one preceding it.
Yeah.
And you worked your chops.
Of course he and Bob,
he was your,
he was your Ike Turner will boy.
Yeah.
He was unforgiving.
And you learn quick of about timing in between transition segway,
you were allowed to do three songs and if he felt your song was too long or
your,
your riff in between,
is he,
oh,
he called you out.
If you didn't like your shoes,
he talked about it.
You never saw him,
you heard it over the PA.
Oh Wow.
He was in the back is quite a ritual and I learned a tremendous amount about how
you communicate with it with a crowd.
How do you talk to people as one,
how do you make eye contact?
What in fact are the wrong shoes?
What are the wrong shoes?
Platforms?
Back in the day they were platforms.
Right?
Okay.
David Leibow eat.
We'll be singing as hopefully a shorter song than the last one.
He's saying last Sunday.
Are you the same?
David?
[inaudible] you would hear this over the guy over the PA system.
When kiss performs today,
do they still wear platforms?
I think it's in the contract.
You know,
it's part of the outfit and Mcenroe has to yell.
You gotta be fucking Keddie they for kiss.
I had never thought of that.
Like they might be the last band that's wearing platforms until it.
Wow.
Everybody likes to make fun of platforms,
Bell Bottoms,
sideburns till they come back around they,
oh there's where there was something there.
Sorry,
I don't know about platforms on guys,
but on the right girl on the right you the head.
Yeah,
I'm fine with high heels.
Right?
Girls in platforms do you know under the rag like oh wow.
That suggests different timeframes.
I think that's the 20s.
That's the 30s.
That could be the 70s.
You know,
there's something about those kiss ones though.
That was like their inexorable right.
They're a part of the GIG.
Like with Gene Simmons,
he's got demon boots like that.
They're still rocking him at,
at those are new and improved costumes too.
Those are digital.
They're definitely new and improved.
Uh,
I like the boots.
I like it,
man.
That has gotta be fucking hell on your knees though.
That's got to be hell on your lower back.
All of the above.
I'm going to leap ahead,
but look,
Stanley's still in shape.
Oh He's,
he looks great.
He was here a couple of years ago.
You know,
this is where I failed.
I should've gone kiss blue man group years ago.
To those of you who are my age lassie,
there should be four of me.
Oh,
that's the move,
right?
Because yeah,
no one could tell.
Right.
That's the thing.
Like you could replace a lot of those guys and if you didn't tell anybody,
and as long as someone's w have you ever heard the Japanese gentlemen that's a,
he does a Steve Perry impression.
He's the new lead singer for journey.
Oh,
he's,
I think he's from Philippines.
Oh,
is he Japanese?
Eighth Way.
Fucking phenomenal from the guy.
Sounds exactly like Steve Perry.
Alright,
well this solicit an interesting subject.
Perhaps compels it,
um,
are some bands like west side story where you can continually revitalize the
production,
right?
With different actors.
It with different actors.
Okay.
A whole lot of Shakespeare going on.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
but you have to kind of replicate the initial sound,
or do you,
as I'm sure all of Beethoven's early orchestras or debt debt is fried chest,
because I don't think you can say this because this was a part of my youth van
Halen was a part of my youth.
I mean,
we used to have to chew the,
the van Halen logo on our notebooks in high school,
along with the rolling stones like the mouth and you know,
I'll kiss logo when it switched over to Sammy Hagar.
It became a different thing.
It was a different thing.
There's a whole different pivot.
I mean,
it wasn't,
it wasn't a bad thing.
No,
no.
But it was a thing.
Shane,
all of Shams lyrics contained love.
Yes.
Okay.
Why can't this be love?
And I ain't talking about lovely,
right back with more fighting after this.
Yeah.
We can come on.
Who Do I jog with?
I don't,
I run who's my running partner?
Yeah.
Running with the devil.
Hello.
Okay.
You want to keep going?
Yeah,
keep going.
Should I jump?
I jump.
Might as well jump.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I mean,
come on.
It's a questions in love Ra.
Great.
Uh,
classically that's [inaudible].
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
but I'm,
I'm not well adjusted.
Nobody in my job ever was much less,
kept it this long and I faced it.
Embraced it.
Where's
your phone?
Oh No,
it's all right there in the lyrics.
Yeah.
Even using what are considered classic music parlor tricks,
taking a very shad lyric and positioning it against a very happy piece of music.
The music is romping itch,
itch,
uh,
heavy metal,
Rumba,
booboo,
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo doop in the lyric is she's crying.
Yeah.
Jamie's crime.
You didn't notice that.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it.
There's a sense there's a sense of larceny does chaos to him in the lyric.
There's this sense of a itch music for after midnight when we're all guilty.
Joan.
Yeah.
Whereas,
and again,
nothing wrong with the Sammy Hagar thing,
but it moved into a mall crowd.
It was a different sort of a vibe.
It was,
it was a good vibe for a lot of folks.
But it was a different vibe.
Um,
I mean I don't have anything against Sammy Hagar.
I think he's wonderful.
I always loved that song.
Can't drive 55 he's got some great shit,
but I never listened to the van Halen with Van Hagar.
I just didn't listen to it.
To me it was like I was an end of an era.
For me it's true dear for folks.
Yes,
I wanted to be the art project,
not just where one
show by placing everything we've discussed.
If you think of it as cross training,
that's a great rationale.
Why did you do that and then you did this and why it's crossed,
trained.
He's got to reinform your shower.
It's going to reinforce the way your stagecraft,
how you even walk out on stage and your choice of what to wear,
who follow your sense of humor especially.
Well that's a great way to look at what you were talking about with the west
side,
west side story analogy because it kind of went on but it Kinda didn't.
It's like if you took west side story in the change the story,
you can't change the story.
But you can change the voices.
Okay.
But it would be a different story.
Like the van Halen story became a different story.
All right.
Here,
I'll venture this.
Okay.
Uh,
one of my favorite freeze dried bands in history is toto.
The last why freeze dried.
Well,
all freeze dried coffee looks the same
and it's great.
I've been camping and man,
there's nothing better than just a cup of fresh freeze dried.
Get it in the rural,
in the wrongest places.
That's fun.
Some context.
It's the best thing you could ever hear that after those songs.
A good song.
It's an amazing Smithsonian level.
Yes.
Song.
Okay.
Rosanna and so forth.
Amazing.
Any of the fellows could walk up to me and I wouldn't recognize him.
No.
You know,
I said would not recognize them.
Fairly say is the greatest genius in all of music in that regard.
Steve Miller,
nobody knows who the fuck Steve Miller is.
Steve Olds.
Yeah.
But mean he had some,
every Hammond knows those songs.
If you stay,
if you even,
uh,
start to play Du,
Du,
and everybody was getting ready to Sing Tanga love God damn.
He had some jams and that guy could go anywhere.
And then there are artists where you just can't replace it.
Rod Stewart arguably one of the best vocals in history of any genre all
together.
Oh yeah.
That's a no weight division thing and yeah,
one of the all time greats.
The Ali is probably Rod Stewart.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
his songs,
you can have other people sing them,
but in a comes something other now journey I would recognize the guitar player,
but that's just because I listened to that kind of,
that part of the band.
Okay.
My favorite part of the orchestra is the Gong.
Just want to clarify that.
But uh,
uh,
Steve Perry who sang for journey.
Okay.
Um,
was not so much a personality as an eloquent sound.
Yes.
All right.
So it's a universal sound and if you even get close to it,
it is part of every prom,
every wedding,
every going in and coming out party.
Okay.
If you're going into the engine,
the army,
that's the last song the band's going to apply.
You're coming out of jail.
They're going to,
your girlfriend's going to pull it.
You throw your bag to the side and run.
You've seen the movie.
Yes.
Okay.
Even Tony Soprano,
we're not sure what happened,
but it happened to journey.
Yes,
true.
That's right.
Yeah.
Right.
Okay.
That's very significant.
You can't play a David Lee Roth Hassan and still worry about Tony Soprano.
That's true.
Your half of your mind is going to go,
wait a minute.
The long ranger just walked in to the same diner that Tony is.
It's why I have no acting career.
I'm already a character.
Lone ranger sits down next to you,
says Joe,
there's a forest.
It's a dark forest and you're not getting lost in any story.
You're sitting in your legs.
You go in is the fucking lone ranger.
Right,
right,
right.
A good actor and sit down and go a dark forest and you're fucking scared.
Right.
Some people can become that other person.
Oh yeah,
and then some people are stuck being David Lee Roth.
Exactly.
You know,
Denzel walks out and then it's face and he go,
wow,
that's an astronaut.
He can be anything.
And he's going to have,
you know,
either
Dave Roth comes,
he goes,
what's Dave doing in a space suit?
Right,
exactly.
Yeah.
We're not buying it.
I'm already a kind of a,
uh,
a cultural yeah,
you're already,
you're already a thing.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a,
that's really interesting how there's all these great bands with great sounds
and great vibes and they're all different.
Well,
you,
if you think in terms of the personality,
let's think of a band.
Oh,
I just saw John Mayer.
Great show.
All right.
And when you think of John,
you think of who that is and the neighborhood and the vibe and the mood before
perhaps you even think of a specific song.
Okay.
Um,
as soon as you know,
well I know his heads,
I know his songs,
but it was the same thing that the fellows in the grateful dead who said they're
identifying that vibe is what's more important.
The jokes or the person.
What's more important you or specific jokes?
Cause some of your jokes are bound to have a go flat.
I don't care.
It's chow.
Yeah.
But some of the Joe,
the only way they,
some of them,
the
only way they work is with you.
Like there's some people like Mitch Hedberg is perfect example.
Like you couldn't separate Mitch Hedberg from the jokes cause he was the jokes.
He was part of what made it funny.
You're right.
I ran into Geoffrey rush the other day.
Okay.
And he did.
Mike bumps in Italian.
Yeah.
Who's managing them?
That's a movie happening.
Those two.
Right.
That's wild.
That's math al lemon fortune cookie.
Yes.
Okay.
Judge.
Only a billion dollar fucking franchises.
Bernie Brillstein stole alive.
Get after this.
Bernie's a lot.
When you get an agent,
it's stellar.
Yes it is.
It is.
If they were walking around in the park doing warmup for their routine,
you know,
and the Netflix special and I'm going,
uh,
I expect the clapboard,
woody Allen to walk out and go.
I think that's a take.
I think though that with guys like that,
especially those two guys eat the best product is them on stage.
Them fucking around.
You really don't want to make a movie.
You just want to keep doing what they're doing with Netflix.
Well this is the,
this is the vibe.
You have them be theirs.
There's some folks like a Jason straighten them.
She always just shame.
So shame.
Haircut.
Yeah.
He's always Jason.
Yes.
Right.
But this Jason in a different time period,
right.
Jason in a fast cars.
Jason on a horse.
I don't know.
He's,
he's always that.
And this is what compels me.
Some folks are very joked dependent now take my wife please.
Yeah.
That kind of thing.
Um,
yeah.
Yourself
is the audience that you see when it's like at the comedy club I've seen yet the
comedy club.
Um,
it's just same audience.
Just fight night.
No,
I was sometimes,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's real similar in a weird way.
Why was it weird?
I see the eye.
She,
uh,
George Michael eyebrows like,
cause I'm always trying to figure it out.
Um,
yeah,
they're,
they're real similar.
You know,
it's a weird crossover,
but what makes it weird?
It's weird that I do cage fighting commentary and standup comedy in the first
place.
It's weird that those two things work together.
Oh,
that doesn't,
uh,
no,
that makes perfect chef for,
you know,
you're,
I just shared with somebody.
I'm funny.
Not Happy.
Yes.
Funny.
You ain't happy.
There's a big difference in the more unhappy you,
you are,
the better.
The funny.
Really think so.
Absolutely.
Really?
If you know how to channel it,
well,
it's certainly the case in some situations.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm open to all possibilities when it comes to comedy.
I know people that are really happy and really funny and I know people that are
really dark and also really funny.
Like,
I don't know,
it's just,
it's different.
It's different with different people.
Just like music is different with different bands and different singers existed.
He either works or it doesn't.
It really depends upon how much time and effort you take working on yourself,
your act,
your,
the
way you deliver it.
We always had to win in Van Halen.
We had no choice.
We had to win the battle of the bands.
It was competitive.
We had to win over the club owner.
This was before there were dance system.
Cerwin Vega hadn't,
hadn't figured out those base binge yet.
And you had to have a live band,
five 45 minute sets a night place.
A motherfucker closer song where you knew a band couldn't go on.
I have to you look ranch.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
we were pretty good at anything.
We had no development phase.
Mm.
Um,
I have tapes of us at the Hilton Hotel in Pasadena in 1973.
You would if I didn't tell Ya,
you know,
you would think it was three years ago.
Wow.
Kind of a sound.
There's virtually no development.
How'd that happen?
How did it work that way?
We had classical training.
Ah,
right.
And this kind of speaks to what we were discussing earlier in that a lot of my
colleagues are having a great time making music and they celebrate and it's,
uh,
the word fun comes into it.
And we grew up in classical music backgrounds where you had to challenge for
first chair saxophone every six,
eight months,
you gotta go to the conductor and say,
I want for his chair.
And if you're first chair and he thinks I have a shy,
he's going to come over and Joyce's Roths talking bout you.
Whoo.
You both,
you both going to play this piece in front of the orchestra next Wednesday,
you best practice.
Ah,
okay.
And we'll both get up and we'll both play 18 bars of the same piece and there
just may be a switch in front of a 120 people.
All of them colleagues.
All right.
We learned from the music school,
you know,
the racy stuff was big band.
All right.
If you're in terms of,
you know,
uh,
we played rocket role in parallel,
but big band,
it's got a square vibe to it because it wound up in elevators in restaurants and
whatever.
But they had cut and contests and there was nothing more cutting than Benny
Goodman versus chick Webb,
big band at Roseland ballroom.
That shit is on.
People would bet on it.
They would play the same four songs.
You play your version of it and we'll play ours.
Wow.
Yeah.
Throw down a big band.
Throw out.
Oh yeah.
And it was furious shit too.
You know,
it wasn't like friendly.
The dancers would stand in the middle of those sparks and that's where you get
that.
Yeah.
He's postures that stuff like this.
Okay.
And the dancers were competing.
The Lindy hoppers could be,
wow,
Frankie can,
you know all these guys,
throw it.
Um,
so it was competitive and we learn that's how you do it.
You know,
my two mentors in,
um,
uh,
music or,
first and second chair clarinet,
the La Philharmonic,
and he comes from that
also,
you know,
you have a whole different vibe that,
uh,
I'll take a grateful dead approach,
which is the complete opposite of that competition,
man.
Leave that at home.
Yeah.
You know,
well,
we're here to celebrate and so,
and I completely understand.
That's where I'll go.
Aft Work,
take my vest off.
But my goodness,
it took a totally different turn.
Right?
They said,
go ahead,
take all of our shows.
Come sell food in the parking lot,
man.
We had to when we or we didn't eat boxing for money,
it's different than boxing for fun.
Right?
Right.
Learned that very early and uh,
we learned it through music.
Yeah.
You know,
some of the folks learn it in the rank.
Other folks learn it in their first few days in a law firm or,
and they join a team.
It's interesting the way you described it with music,
because I try to explain that to comedians.
I say think about how much time a musician has to spend practicing and how
little we spend practicing.
We were,
our practice is in front of the audience for the most part.
It's just simplified version of the 10 big apartment.
A simplified version of the,
how many hours rule is the 10,000 hours you've heard about it.
Yes.
That's a very simplified version.
Okay.
That's digestible.
10,000 hours.
I Dunno,
you break that down.
Was it take a six years maybe something like this.
The True Asian paradigm is 10 hours a day.
Every single day for 10 years.
If you have a little,
a little kid and he's got to have heart surgery,
you want that guy,
right?
It's right around 30,000 hours.
If you're going to go flying in a helicopter over New York,
Shitty,
you want captain Paulie Trim on Todd,
it's about 40,000 hours.
Okay?
Uh,
my dentist,
Doctor Glassman who teaches is a 40,000 hour man.
Okay?
So if you ever crash or get pelted gimme call,
I will hook you up.
It's about 30,000 hours in,
that's 10 hours a day,
every single day for 10 years.
And that's what creates,
uh,
a jet pilot,
a great surgeon,
a great writer.
Yeah.
Well,
anything in the arts and letters,
that's,
that's the architect.
Unless you're a prodigy and you feel bungle that and typing it's tragedy very
easily.
So yeah,
pride and joys and tragedies often go hand in hand.
There's something about people that get things very easily that for whatever
reason,
it slips through their fingers more quickly as well.
When my shifts or my dad was an eye surgeon.
Okay.
Did well and uh,
uh,
when my sisters,
wanting to go to college,
he should,
I think that's a great idea and made her pay for it.
Oh,
she wouldn't value it if she didn't pay for it herself.
That's probably right.
I signed my first contract when I was $1,350 stereo and a three records.
I worked all summer shoveling shit at the local a horse stable.
It's where I learned Spanish.
I don't know that you got it.
Do that.
You learned the same thing from sports.
Yeah.
Your kids do sports.
Which ones?
Um,
martial arts and a one of them is really into gymnastics.
Yeah.
Are they competitive in it or are they,
do they enjoy themselves?
Are they on team?
Like there are tournaments or,
and is that something that
the get y'all here,
I'll back up.
I'm leading up to something.
Can you get,
I think you always are folks.
Folks are starting to recognize certain traits in me as in I really like the
getting ready more than the actual show.
Really.
You actual show.
I'm making fun here and be being poetic,
but the monitor blows.
The guitar players pissed
the spotlights on the wrong guy.
I have a cold but that six months,
six weeks leading up to it,
I remember the rehearsal,
we did it if it's a thing and hey,
when we recorded the track over that they remember when we got measured for the
shoes that fucking,
oh,
it was great and it's,
where did we eat after that?
I got to go back there and Andy,
Andy,
yeah.
I always shot to make those rehearsals and whatever as memorable as possible
because you can do a whole lot more getting ready then are throwing the punch.
Yeah.
Ask anybody on one of your shows.
Yes.
Yeah.
You have such a great insight for that though.
You know some people they,
even if they're aware of it,
they're not consciously aware of it.
They're not focusing on all these details.
The getting ready.
He's as much of a,
if the band says they don't like rehearsing,
you're doing it wrong.
Hey Man.
It's like if you're sitting on your laurels,
you're wearing them.
On the wrong part of your body.
First off,
where are you rehearsing?
Right?
As in Miami?
No.
Where are you training?
Hawaii.
Cleveland.
Okay.
Let's talk,
cause even in Cleveland
you can turn it into your place.
Do you follow?
What is your routine?
If all,
what music did you listen to?
You dig?
How did you warm up?
Simple,
simple things.
You know,
most people are feared,
terrified of singing when they go in to sing it.
Now I don't care who it is.
The first verse is always a little tight in the second versus a little better.
Why?
Because they didn't warm up.
Right.
All right,
and the idea of we'll go in and sing along with a dozen of your favorite songs.
Put your head gear on.
Get the reverb to Santa for me.
That starts with Motown.
I'm a sole growler.
I'm the,
I'm closer to Wilson Pickett.
Then the guy in the rolling stones,
that is bad.
I don't know what that sounds like on the headphones,
you know,
that's,
I spent many.
I'm going to put the headphones on here that,
there we go.
Lao Bag.
Yeah,
that's right.
I started sounding like that when I was 12.
I started practicing that when I was 12.
I started imitating the persuasions,
Jerry Butler to singer,
um,
let us 13,
much to the cantors,
Chagrin in Hebrew school.
Okay.
Again,
parallel existences.
You know,
I'm Jewish,
but we always walked around with little buttons.
Back then it said never again.
I'm a combat hippie.
Peace,
love and heavy weapons.
Some people don't believe you.
Sometimes you got to get an assistant.
Did you ever
realize while you were,
while you were in the middle of this,
especially in the beginning,
the early days,
that
this was,
that you guys had,
especially with van Halen in the early days,
you guys had a massive impact on culture.
Where you guys aware of that?
Like while it was happening,
how,
I mean you,
you,
when I was in high school,
I went,
I graduated in 1985 and you guys were the shit.
My girlfriend might,
my sister's rather boyfriends,
uh,
my sister's boyfriend's licensing.
I am the soundtrack.
The soundtrack to your okay.
I get it.
Yes,
absolutely.
I mean,
what was that?
That the gym was intentional.
It was intentional.
I can tell you now,
the heelan's knew it,
but can't articulate it.
But right there instrumentalists.
Here comes the funny joke words M my thing,
right?
You understood the words in my thing.
So you realized that while it was happening.
Well,
your end game depends on how you started.
It's like chess.
Right.
And we began very early on identifying that there's a whole lot of different
neighborhoods and southern California.
I knew this from being with my dad,
all of his patients.
Whereas like a Benetton ad com.
Yeah.
Right.
You know,
that's part of the beauty of passive data.
You got everybody.
Okay.
What you play at the birthday party in the Spanish speaking neighborhood.
Oh,
rally.
Santana.
You got to change [inaudible] Bro.
Yeah.
Is Different than what we're going to play for the surfers out of Venice beach.
That's Aerosmith stuff.
Uh,
you know,
and do like this.
And then you have the working man.
Okay.
Out in San Bernardino and that Zz top double d two too subtle but important
geniuses in the details and how you interact with that crowd in between.
We would play out in Pomona at a biker bar.
Guy got killed right in front of us and we finished the song.
What happened?
A couple of buying a bike.
Gangs went at it and uh,
there was a scrap and when everybody cleared out,
there was a fellow right in the middle of the floor.
Next night we came back,
vengeance had been sworn,
there were police everywhere.
We've pulled the amps out from the wall so we could hide behind the amps and
seventies,
and it was a mighty task.
Wow.
And we played on the Queen Elizabeth for remotely fancy.
Oh my God.
I remember sitting in that ballroom at four in the morning in the days when we
carried our own equipment and stuff and thinking of all the people who had been
in there and everybody to perform there and so forth,
and dozens and dozens of places,
you know,
that we're all a little bit different.
And our,
our thing was that we could play anywhere we had to otherwise,
uh,
we had feed ourselves.
All right.
And that meant five 45 minutes.
That's a night.
Five,
six nights.
If you could get it and we would ping pong all over the Southland anywhere.
We could drive for two hours,
two hours north,
south or east is how we would do in every neighborhood was a little different.
And that shows up in the music,
you know,
now you can take a look at something like dancing the night away or Jamie's
crying.
There's a,
there's a Latino influence in that.
Okay.
We do do,
do,
that's Ricky Ricardo.
People say,
what's your favorite Cuban expecting me to name his cigars?
I,
Ricky Ricardo,
[inaudible] ditch Rumba,
Rumba,
Du,
du Du.
Now you're thinking about it,
you go,
yeah,
and kid.
And if he was in a dance the night away,
the middle break is all Cha-cha.
Chatchki is definitely a,
because here,
this is,
you know,
you're surrounded by Hispanic culture here and we had heavy metal.
Okay.
We had a super wealthy stuff.
So you have to be able to move to acoustic.
You gotta be able to ease up if you get hired for a wedding.
And more importantly perhaps,
you know,
artists to artists.
I Dunno Springsteen better during the song or in between.
Careful we're going to the Broadway show.
Yeah,
that's about a $12,000 ticket now.
And I'm guessing,
I'm guessing before t shirt and I'm guessing that uh,
I haven't seen the whole show.
I saw some of it on Netflix and the very pivot of it is the in between songs.
Yeah.
The songs are almost secondary.
You know,
they're almost peripheral to his narration in his descriptions and his poetry
when he sets a deep guy,
like you have to hear the in between stuff.
You want to hear him brewed,
you want to hear him talk,
you want to hear him think about things.
Yes.
And where do you learn that or dealing that
already?
I'm going to count to 30,000 Joe hours and hours and hours and when we're done
you'll be able to,
you know,
Joe,
that's not a good Springsteen.
You know,
you're a good man.
Jo.
What I was trying to get at was like,
does it ever freak you out?
Like when you ever alone and you think about what you guys did and what you've
done in your career,
does it ever freak you out?
But the impact that you've had that if you looked at the amount of human beings
that have had the kind of impact that you've had,
it's the tiniest,
tiniest fraction of a percent.
Like the amount of human beings that can relate to your personal life
experience.
I'll paraphrase the James Brown movie.
There's two of them.
Both of them were helpful to helpfully produced by Jagger.
Okay.
And he does an interview.
He goes down a little bit of me in every record you hear.
Oh
yeah,
he's in the DNA.
Yeah.
He's a little bit of David Lee Roth in there.
There's a little bit,
whenever you see videos today,
doesn't matter if it's hip hop,
doesn't matter if it's rock and roll.
It doesn't matter if it's classic or pit bull.
Can you dig?
There's a lead.
You can trace it back if follow,
and it's not a,
I don't think of it as impact.
That's a result.
What's the verb?
Contribution.
Yeah,
at family reunions,
whatever.
We go around,
everybody picks a word and uh,
my favorite word ever was to contribution.
Did you try,
you know,
go climb the tree.
Here's my favorite poem.
I saw it inscribed on a rock by an anonymous poet at the base.
Just short of base camp at Everest.
Go climbed the treasure mountain.
Do not return empty handed.
Where are you now?
Hmm.
Ooh,
Ooh.
Yeah.
That's some gps shit.
What's interesting about music that's different than anything else to is it
brings you back to the moment where you heard it or when it was significant to
you or were,
you know,
like if I hear dance the night away,
if I'm in my car and dancing hideaway comes on,
it's just like,
God,
you get goosebumps.
She's just,
you have this feeling.
You feel like you're back in Newton,
Massachusetts in high school.
My favorite audience is disbelieving nonbelievers.
Non smilers.
Give me a room in North Korea who hate everything about the trip.
Starting with the airport.
Get Disney.
Like why those they hate rock and roll.
You give me two choruses.
Sato Ah,
first we're going to drive away the evil spirits.
You might use a little volume to do that show and then I use a little of this.
Here we go.
Just drive with evil spirits and then I'm going to make you feel young as kitty.
How much is that worth for the nest?
Nesta.
Inestimable.
Yeah,
that,
that's the thing about music that's different than anything else.
It,
it really does change your mood.
It elevates.
You can do that.
It gives you the juice.
It's also we have like like a big glass bowl.
Are you whole history and we and no movies don't do that.
Books will,
if you used a paper back and you open it up and the pages are still dried from
the vacation son,
you know you were reading it at the beach and the salt air made the pages kind
of old and dry and crackly and some sand comes out and he'd get the memory.
Yeah.
All right.
Music,
we'll take you right back.
Right back,
right back.
The women will feel desirable.
You will feel invulnerable.
You guys are making songs like saying running with the devil,
something like that.
How do you know when you're done?
No,
it's not.
When you're done itch,
how'd you get there?
Right.
That informs the whole thing.
Okay.
Um,
somebody asked me once,
uh,
how long did it take you to write running with the devil?
And that's an astute question.
I should.
Well the true answer is
if you watch a thousand movies,
many of the multiple times,
if you've played thousands and thousands of hours in clubs and bars,
okay.
If you've read,
I don't know,
500 books,
tried to memorize all the good parts,
take about 18 minutes.
Write the song.
So you guys wrote running with the devil and 18 minutes.
Yeah.
Really?
Yes.
Jesus Christ.
Okay,
but doesn't rhapsody in blue,
right?
Duh.
Right.
It took 22 minutes to come up with the basic theme in the rest of it's
improvisation.
How would you guys,
right,
how would you guys get together and do it?
The whole point is not the 18 minutes.
It's the whole lifetime before it.
It's everything that led up to that.
Now,
Van Halen,
we never took a demo tape around cause we didn't get lost in the stack.
We should have.
We're as good as we think we are,
they'll come find us.
And if they don't,
we're not.
Wow.
So I'm forgiving instead of the requisite two and a half,
three years it takes for most acts.
We spent five and a half years working the clubs and the bars and everything
like that.
So we came in with scars and stars.
We'd been,
we'd done the state fair circuit
like that.
I wasn't exactly new.
Same thing for Springsteen.
He'd done 10 years in the clubs and bars before.
Yeah.
You know,
thunder road and whatnot.
And you'll see this routinely.
I think the Beatles did four or five years of working in the red light district.
Reeperbahn and all the club shows and stuff like that.
And they're adding up.
They're getting that 10,000 and then ultimately that 30,000 hour mark.
Yeah.
Beatles.
There's a thing,
it's Malcolm Gladwell's book where he's talking about,
uh,
the Beatles and they're there when they came up,
when they were performing in Germany and they were doing these shows where they
were doing multiple sets at night every night of the week.
And that this is really what made them so good is this constant performing,
that they were doing it so much and so often that they just became this smoothly
oiled machine.
If you have a team that you're working together,
again,
this is another kind of thing I learned along the way on 40 hours a week is
about your minimum.
If there's a team,
like we're a rugby team or a Swat team or uh,
uh,
emergency room,
kind of a c block kind of,
you know,
intensive like that inner city intensive,
we call it Vietnam.
Sometimes it'd take like that 40 hours a week,
his bachelor minimum that you need to train together in order to be going
without looking at each other.
When the lights go out,
you're,
you don't lose velocity,
so to speak.
All right?
Um,
ultimately you'll start to look like each other.
This is the nature of things.
The Beatles look like each other.
Van Halen,
we looked like each other.
We all have the same haircut.
We wear the same leather jackets to say fairs.
We became a team.
It was the golden times.
You know,
these are the golden years that most people look back on before.
The friction of time,
uh,
implicates itself.
You get married,
you have kids,
sure you bump your elbow.
Now I gotta get my elbow worked on.
And as you know,
and just the friction of time,
the rent expands,
you know,
contracts,
et cetera.
Um,
and
people routinely look back on that as the golden years.
You know,
your gang,
everybody had one look back in,
in graphic arts,
you know,
the Picasso's and the dollies and everybody wandered around in gangs.
The great writers in New York all hung out together and they didn't get along.
You're always competing with each other.
You're pretending to love each other.
It dig and just read in the New York magazine some advice from the uh,
art critic Jerry Salts.
It says,
create gangs.
And remember,
always treat the weakest one is your best friend because there's somebody else
in the gang who thinks you're the weakest one.
And that's what you learn.
You know,
as you go,
what are you gonna learn from working the clubs and the bars and stuff?
Well,
my stringers broke,
my nose is running.
I'm angry.
My girlfriend just ran off with two and not one guy.
Should I keep going?
I'm underpaid.
Non respected late
and now I'm starting to sound like double Dutch bus to top it off.
I'm late to work.
I got bad feet and McLarens hurt
and you're going to play.
You will perform.
Okay.
Just as you will expect that surgeon at four in the morning.
This is my little baby girl.
That unforgiving.
Apply that to your art.
Ooh.
See each words.
Okay.
Sage,
words of advice.
You have expectations.
You may not have used them yet.
Yeah.
Okay.
When you guys wrote songs,
how did you,
how did you put the lyrics to the music?
What was the process like?
How did you guys sort that out?
So you,
would you come to them with an idea?
Would they come to you with a riff?
Like how would,
how would it work?
It'll work,
uh,
a number of ways.
But a mistake that a lot of young writers in my department,
the lyrics make is that they think of it as secondary.
Mm.
They wait for the music or the track first and then you'll walk into a studio
and hope that the hand of God will descend and grace you with a amazing
epiphany's.
I can't even spell amazing.
All right.
Um,
and called upon to do it right away.
You know,
you'll work out a beat and go,
Dave,
you got some lyrics.
If I go walk into that room and try to create it right.
Nine Times out of 10,
it's going to be moon in June.
Right?
Moon in June.
Really?
When?
Sometime soon.
What time of day?
I'm thinking noon and literally I'm going to put my hands in the air.
Why?
Well,
cause I just don't care.
You wind up there unless you're banking.
Think like debate.
If you're going to debate somebody,
you're banking your ideas,
right?
Alright.
And whatever the subject is,
you can go,
shh.
Don't even have to have a subject.
It's okay.
I like what he just said.
I might even write that phrase.
I like what you just said.
Could be a Drake lyric.
Dig any expressions,
ideas,
slogans,
uh,
anything that comes from other tunes in terms of their lyrics and is everybody
contributing?
No,
that's just me.
Just to have volumes of that and those kinds of ideas,
ideas for songs,
storylines,
et Cetera.
Um,
you would never go into a fight without doing that.
Collecting moves from every other film of every other fighter that you possibly
can,
so that when somebody goes like this,
you go,
oh,
I know what to do.
So and so from Muslims [inaudible] then I'm going to visit like this and
somebody says it's a song about they play a song.
I go,
wow,
it sounds kinda like cowboy music.
Let's write about back cowboys going through the banking.
Giddy up.
That's cool.
Title.
I heard a cowboy,
I say it on the TV set and I wrote it down literally.
Okay.
And you start bay,
you get,
I see the lights
and you start banking.
Okay.
Somebody says something you dig.
Um,
I heard somebody,
a waitress named pepper
with an unlit pall mall cigarette.
Tell me,
oh honey.
Nothing could have stopped us back then.
Anyway.
That's a title.
That is a title.
I wrote a song to it.
Did you?
Oh yeah.
Where was this waitress on the road?
Just to,
well,
she also had something else to say.
She leaned over,
she showed me that that cleavage a little bit and she'd,
and she'd go keep your four county.
There's Pie,
excuse me,
I guess.
And you're right it down.
Yeah.
Banking.
I liked the term they use in debate.
Your banking,
banking,
your ideas.
So when you would on the road and someone say something that you would
physically write it down,
go home and write it down today.
Today.
All the time.
Bank.
Yeah.
And it goes into the books and then when it's time to deal with a given,
soon as you listen to music,
if the music came first and you
don't know what's just like,
remind yourself.
Oh,
that sounds like Kung Fu.
That sounds like country.
Right.
That sounds like a engines are coming.
It's a and on and on.
It follows.
You might suggestion,
idea to write things down physically or do you type them?
I sh I print.
Print,
yeah.
And I,
I paint and draw routinely.
Okay.
As you know,
as part of the martial arts.
Okay,
sure.
Musashi.
Yep.
But uh,
when I was in Japan,
uh,
two and three nights a week,
I,
well we call it training.
I did assume Yay.
With a Sumi eight teachers direct Sumia it's um,
like calligraphy,
pen and ink in,
in the world of the digital future.
I spent two years practicing four shades of gray and two shades of black.
Oh yeah.
You want to see my lesson?
Can you do,
can you focus a camera if I stand up?
Can you,
you well,
here's my lesson.
Okay.
I'm going to walk from here to here.
I'm here painting.
Okay.
I'm the only guy in the room.
Ready?
Okay.
Here we go.
No.
Yeah.
Okay.
After six months I heard better Jesus Christ.
After almost 10 months a shit.
Then he goes,
Mr Rod,
I think you are my best student.
Oh,
I should not my painting.
He said,
no,
not your painting.
You Shit.
You are most determined.
You are most sincere.
You really enjoy most like this.
Thank you sir.
He should.
I wish to invite you to director's meeting.
Show me a society.
Whoa,
that's,
I made the same face.
I said,
whoa.
When his dad should right now we pulled out a bottle of Saki chew little cups,
became one of my best friends in Tokyo.
Wow.
First Shit for six seconds.
First six months,
I might've got some word.
Well,
for a guy like that,
in this day and age,
it must be insanely difficult to get someone to have that sort of appreciation
for commitment.
Well,
it's,
it's a national thing.
Okay.
You learn that stuff in grade school and it's sorta like classes.
Painting and calligraphy is as well known as perhaps piano lessons.
And what were you thinking while you were doing all this?
While you're learning this and spending months and months?
I focus on specifically that knowing that at the end of the term I'm going to be
a little,
I don't know.
I'm sharpening things a little bit and when I'm called upon even to have a
discussion like this.
Yeah.
I,
I can bring a little contribution to it.
Yeah.
It can be more entertaining for all of you listening to this.
It can,
you know,
that's an amazing recognition that you have though,
that you realized while you were doing this,
that even though consciously all you're doing is doing calligraphy,
you're working on other parts of your mind.
Oh,
I knew I was never going to pay for shit.
50 shades a Dave.
But you were still focusing 100% of your energy on doing it while you're doing
it.
Yeah.
And there's something to that.
Yeah,
it's the preparation.
What are you doing now?
That's weird.
Oh,
well I went corporate.
You okay?
Oh yeah.
I got 34 employees.
You do it.
I have offices at one park avenue and you see a guy who might go off the grid
and be very difficult to find in the offices at the beach.
And My company is a GS words,
were about $8 million into it here.
Running that kind of a team and dealing with the people because it's art
centric.
What does this team,
what's it about?
And it just is the attaches to the original.
This is my stuff.
And I didn't just hire a bunch of people to pass things in front of me.
I designed what that logo looks like.
I put together what the general everything.
Okay.
The air all.
And then I hired the architect and said,
build this,
create this.
So it's virtually everything that you know how to do as an artist because you
have to keep everybody entertained.
You have to be creative on levels.
Everything from Adobe Photoshop to social engineering in platforming dealing
with marketing,
publishing,
all the way that publishing is changing.
Magazines now make e digital.
Are you approaching this the same way you approach calligraphy?
Oh,
you bet.
Art centric,
singing and dancing paid every penny for the company.
And this is what I bring to it.
Mostly when you have a celeb get involved in something like that.
I don't know.
J Lo does fashion.
She's not really taking a pen and ink and drawing out doors and drawing out the
clothes.
Somebody passes things in front of her and she makes sounds,
I'm assuming it goes like this.
I'm the guy who has to interpret those sounds.
And,
and,
and in cause there's gotta be a sense of humor,
right?
Mixed in name of my company is laugh to win and it doesn't have anything to do
with mirth.
Hmm.
Well all the best pirates laugh,
especially if it's the last one.
Oof.
Um,
few of these are going to detonate on the freeway home.
No.
Sure.
And when you were,
when you were,
how much of your time,
how much time is involved in this?
No significant amount of time or back and forth.
And uh,
so you're like a real professional now.
Like over professional corporate dude.
You look,
you can do that.
The 50 hour work week thing and no,
no,
no.
It's arch and trick.
Okay.
Alright.
Um,
it starts with what was the need,
what was the,
well,
the need that is like when Al Honnold goats climbing,
he's going to put on some sunblock and he doesn't want to touch that shit for
another four hours.
Right.
So I built it for him.
Kay.
I,
I cracked my two Maulers and walked around for three years with no molders on
this side of my head when I caught Dang gay fever.
Whoa.
Okay.
Cause the sunblock and the stuff that had the mosquito shit and it washed off
when I got out of the Oh shit.
So I solved it.
And we are stripper friendly but we are not strippers so I don't want Shanie
so it's like I want,
I want satin.
Hello.
Okay.
I don't want to shiny.
There's room for shiny like,
you know,
Friday nights.
Sure.
And as far as fragrances,
thank you know.
Hmm.
Okay.
Um,
it took three years and more than you want a quote to solve that because every
time you go and you smell something,
you crack the jar of anything.
Somebody has played with that and probably in New Jersey.
Okay.
Think like this.
I'm already doing the pitch.
You like ice cream.
You don't,
your kids do gelato even better.
Okay.
Suppose you want to make a coconut vanilla.
All right.
Well,
if you're buying most products,
you got to just go to one factory in New Jersey.
True Story.
The L'Oreal's,
the neutrogenas is so forth and they're going to take the smell of coconut and
the smell of vanilla and it's in it makes it so forth.
This kind of a thing.
The fact is the cow lives in a very different place than the coconut lady who
grows coconuts and the guy who's going to sell you your vanilla lives in a whole
nother country.
The reason that ice cream taste so good as somebody got their ass on an airplane
and flew to all three places and that's what my staff does.
Our staff is artistic.
It's like craft scotch
from the Carolinas.
Which port puts your,
uh,
Pendleton on?
We're going to Portland
really?
And then we're going to go to Seattle because that's just one product.
It's my artists and all art thing that I do there.
And it came from a need behind the scenes started years ago when we'd be
climbing and stuff would get all over our hands and all over our ropes.
We'd be kayaking and somebody keep dropping the yours cause something was
slippery.
You follow?
Yeah.
So okay,
someday I'm going to solve this.
Someday I'm going to solve this.
When you're in your 20s,
there's an Aha moment when you're my age,
there's more than one.
And that's when we went out high again,
third time today.
And we began to expand,
laugh to win,
make ink the original.
And we have 60 other products coming up.
All of it developed for people who live in vans like Alex Honnold,
folks who live in transit at hotels,
people who live urban camping is what we do,
especially me and my tour bus.
Everything I do is in the disco submarine.
We travel and you got to be familiar everywhere.
Even Canada,
even Canada
and,
and today we traveled the entire world with impunity.
You've got to South America,
you go to Europe and something as simple.
When you go to Japan,
you're really going to go fine.
Dental floss on,
you're on now.
You're not pale face.
You got to take me cause otherwise you're doing Pantha mine.
Yeah.
Wait until you get a bad stomach and you got a pan of mine that to the little
way.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
all of these things.
Okay.
I gotta stay Bois.
She got to fit in my backpack.
Every container has to be able to be sat on in a third world airport.
You gotta be able to,
Stevie wonder it in your backpack.
It's an insensitive illusion analogy,
but every one of our containers is such that you can stick your hand in the bag
while you're driving and find it.
I'm safety conscious.
What do you have kids in the car?
So was done by design.
The shape of the package is done by design so you could absolutely,
absolutely.
What does it look like?
She won't pull it up.
Jamie,
you can read our logos from across the Atlantic Ocean.
Right?
Having worked and played Aaron the diner.
Okay.
Suppose your granddaddy
doesn't speak English.
[inaudible] okay.
All of our products,
you have this kind of low going here.
All right,
so translate this to Granddad into Cambodia and Granddad.
You're going to water,
exercise.
Everybody there is going to have their own.
Take Yours.
Make sure grandma puts this one on and that works in 82 languages.
I like the logo.
Okay,
thank you.
Cool looking little of sunscreen.
Thank you.
You got hand grip and kiss,
you're wearing gloves at work in.
A lot of times when we're waiting in the projects.
Okay,
and the rainstorms,
you're wearing two gloves,
you got your rubber gloves and you got your duty gloves on.
Right?
You still got the no slip grip on the side.
Fair enough.
And you got a daughter,
right?
She's going to grow up to be somebody.
Right.
And hanging around with guys and controlling guys.
My Dad worked in the prison system the last 20 years of his life.
K did eye surgeries up in Folsom,
San Quinten,
Norco,
Pelican Bay,
Cetera,
little skinny Jewish doctor.
How do you control level for violent lifers theater.
Okay.
You're going to tell your daughter,
don't pull anything pink out of your purse.
If you're sitting with a bunch of guys,
pull that stuff out.
It's the right color,
right?
If you're at a legal briefing,
you gotta be a boss.
Don't pull any Surillian blue,
especially if it's shiny vinyl out of your purse.
You can't have a purple that pull that.
Yeah.
It says boss.
In 22 lang,
what's in it?
Like,
what's in it that makes it work?
Well,
look,
that makes it waterproof and it's 100%,
uh,
in the,
brightener for example,
it's organics.
Okay.
A brightener while it makes your tattoo shiny,
you bet.
And it stays on just shorter forever.
It's days on when you go swimming,
so forth.
Okay.
And what do you always do when somebody goes,
hey,
what's that new piece symbol?
You Lick your finger
and you're of it and you show it before it dries out.
Okay,
I'm going to deal with the vanity's as guys.
You never want to say you give a shit.
Right.
I would teach my kid to say that if I add one,
hey,
your tattoos looking a little rusty.
I don't give a shit.
Learn how to say that in a few languages.
Right?
But you know,
you give a shit,
otherwise you wouldn't have gotten the paint job.
Right.
And you want the girls to know you've got a peace symbol anyways,
cause you look kind of me like me.
Great.
Put your finger away.
Will you?
We've got to clean up.
That's a bacterial thing.
So what's enough stuff?
You're going to make all the mistakes too.
You're going to go out and you're going to try and find cheap shit.
Moisturizers did you get to put on there and you're going to smear it all over
yourself and it's just going to look like that scene from something about Mary
when she puts that shit
and everybody's gonna think was as shit all over Bobby's arm like this and it's
going to get all over your tee shirt and your wife has a $600 tee shirt,
doesn't she Joe?
Okay,
so you got to consider all of this.
Okay.
I saw a nice car out there.
I'm guessing there's nice upholstery in it.
Yeah,
I took that into consideration and got you covered.
Oh,
okay.
And why not?
And it's the smell of victory there.
Nothing's vitamin C,
shea butter and coconut oil not tested on animals.
Dermatologist reviews,
man were paraben-free petroleum free.
We aren't full list of ingredients.
Here we go.
What is all this jazz?
We are one of the few products here that is reef safe allowable in Hawaii.
Okay.
The limit of what's going into the oceans now and the tourist areas of world.
In Hawaii,
you can count on one hand the products they're allowing to be used on the
beaches and even in the swimming pools and stuff now.
So that comes to us.
This is a whole a hundred percent organic stuff.
It's on waxes and butters.
Yep.
When people talk about miracle ingredients,
I don't know,
I think in terms of there's water and then there's Fiji,
uh,
butter,
eggs,
sugar,
flour.
That's all that there is in the bakery.
All right.
We invented the cronut.
Okay.
You take the best of this and the best of that.
And the considerations again,
come from life experience.
I didn't just look at myself and go,
wow,
uh,
here's an idea to make money.
My fortune has been made.
What we did is fine.
What we can use when we're living out of backpacks,
what we can use when we go dancing.
I still go dancing and I don't leave that floor for four hours.
Where do you go dancing?
I'm not telling you no go.
Oh yeah.
Routine.
Really?
Oh,
you bet.
Where are you?
Where are you going to show that ink?
Right.
Follow up today.
I know in New York City for example,
Mr Chinn lives right next to Mr. Gomez.
They both live over.
Mr Katzenberg,
Mr Radda Covich owns the building.
None of them can speak to each other.
They all speak a different language,
they're all different religions,
et cetera.
So there's two ways we communicate.
First is swearing.
You know how to do that,
right?
You learn seven,
eight words and swearing.
You can describe anything.
This shows the shit,
Joe,
you're the shit.
Thank you.
What kind of Shit are you doing lately?
That last fight?
That was the shit.
And we're having a conversation,
right?
Okay.
Legs Up.
And the next is inc uh,
she got a chicken on one arm and a cleaver.
You butcher
and
the girl down there,
he's got cupcakes with funny noses.
Let me guess.
He's got musical notes.
Can I guess more?
Right?
And,
and
in an Esperanza,
you walk out in front of Columbia University at lunchtime,
it's the future.
You would not know that it's United States.
It is a complete composite international.
Just the smell of all the food trucks.
The last thing you smell is salami and yellow cheese on white bread.
Thank God.
Say thank God and a few other languages.
Really.
Okay.
So it's a communication and that's part of my fascination with it.
It's a constantly evolving Esperanto art form.
I've visited tribes in New Guinea who can't dance.
They don't have,
they don't dance,
but they did have tattooing.
They did have scars.
Ice Man.
They found it a glacier.
That guy,
uh,
you know,
they found his body,
I forget what they call it,
Africa,
what his name is,
but he had tattoos on him.
I mean,
he's thousands of years old that Fabio
Joe,
doesn't he go to your gym?
Jamie's as I see him all the time,
they still look good.
But Fabio is very recognizable.
Fabio is like sideburns and flares and a easy listening.
We always make fun.
But there's one of them in your past that guide,
banked on his hair.
I mean,
if that guy went bald like me,
he'd be fucked.
It still is the exact same.
Fabulous,
right?
Amazing genetics.
He got a lucky break.
He's one of the characters.
Who are other characters like that?
Oh,
David Hasselhoff sore now has a hassle book.
What does that,
well,
he has his own Facebook thing and he's met so many.
I got the disdain look from Joe.
Got a hassle,
not smiler.
Oh my God.
Housel book.
He is fucking cold colo here.
Have you guys cold?
I hassle come.
Holy Shit.
Who was uh,
Anna Nicole Smith?
Yeah,
she,
there's three.
There's three phases.
First phase,
pretty big guest genes ad correct.
Right.
And then there's married to the old dude.
Well,
I'm a little Janky.
I kind of liked the last one to the rich right before she dies.
Elvis had three phases.
So,
uh,
yeah,
but there are folks also that don't have phases.
Springsteen never had aphasia was always Springsteen there and is looking good.
Fabio,
he's about 85 years old still.
I mean,
I don't see him working out a lot,
but he's there.
What does he do if he's at the gym?
I don't know.
Talking to a women.
Oh Damn.
Still scoring.
No,
but
that's,
that's so cre,
you want to think about it but you don't,
but you do,
but you don't.
Yeah.
You want to think about the guy that wants a bank.
Fab.
Fabulous.
Super pumped about it.
He's coming over in five minutes.
I've got to get ready.
What are you watching on TV?
Do you have television?
Yes.
And what are you watching regular like cause I don't have television.
I listened to serious Jack Sham routinely.
I listened to like six different channels over and over again there.
Lately I'm watching the Marvelous Mrs Maizel,
which is a a net.
It's a not nothing for,
excuse me,
it's an Amazon show.
It's an Amazon original show about a standup comedian in the 1950s when women
stand,
standup comedian who hangs out with Lenny Bruce.
It's really good.
Okay.
Really good show women standup comedian.
There's a great subject.
Sherif Silverman.
Yeah.
Hooray.
Spectacular.
Right.
She has a real hurdle because one of the things that she does best is play the
part of the character she's lampooning.
Sure.
Yeah.
She plays the part beautifully of a witless.
Yup.
Racist,
whatever.
And her hurdle is that a large segment of the audience doesn't realize that it's
an act.
Well now.
Now that's the hurdle.
Especially now if you go back and look at some of her older bits and look at any
special,
if you looked at it written down as opposed to her sang it.
We're in such an overwhelmingly sensitive time when it comes to subject matter
that yeah,
that would be a big hurdle for now,
but it's the best work ever and it made such an impact.
The first time I ever saw her do it,
and this is a tradition that goes all the way back.
Back during Lincoln,
there was a fellow who wrote the Nas be letters where he pretended to be a
southern racist and making fun of southern racism by pretending to be Lincoln
kept the articles clipped from the newspaper in his drawer so he could read them
occasionally and laugh during the civil war.
You know,
this is a tradition of acting out the character that you are about to execute.
Unfortunately,
there's a lot.
What?
What is the chemistry that folks don't understand that you are pretending they
don't care.
It's not.
It's a dishonest approach.
They don't care whether or not you're pretending what they see.
You have said something or there's something written that shows that you said
something that they feel is in violation and so they want to go after it.
It,
it doesn't make illiterates.
Yes,
it's literal and it's also,
it's disingenuous because they know it could be parody and they don't care.
There's so much of that today.
It's really interesting.
It's really interesting because there's so many people that are,
they just looking for things to be upset about.
It's a recreational outrage and I think it's probably because things are going
so well in this world.
I mean it's not,
I mean some people say it's not going that well.
You know,
there's a lot of things to be fixed.
For sure.
It's is the safest time
to be alive ever.
It just is.
Is is undeniably the safest tongue agree with that and I think people are more
open minded than ever or more kind than ever.
There's less violence than ever.
All the,
if you look at Pinker's work,
all these things are trending in a very,
very clear and obvious direction.
And I think when you have coddled mines and you have more safety,
people start running around looking for things to be upset at the end.
And also a lot of young people that are very idealistic think they're going to
change the world.
And one of the ways are going to change the world's by policing language and
policing the way people talk about things and discuss things.
And so standup comedy,
which is,
you know,
you say a lot of things you don't really mean cause they're funny.
You know,
that's the whole point behind it.
And so it's ripe as far as a target for that kind of recreational outrage.
The musical equivalent perhaps is really shitty songs written about important
subjects.
Yeah.
Really shitty songs written about important subjects are offensive.
They write the melody sound,
reminds you of overdue dentist appointments.
Sounds like why hot water being thrown in this example,
but it's about starving children.
Right?
What's a good example?
No,
don't go there.
We don't need to do that.
But we all know this.
We're all thinking,
yeah,
we all do.
And if you criticize the song,
even if you say it's just musically,
that sounds like we shall overcome.
Whoa,
that's about patch.
Yeah.
I love pets.
Beautiful.
You just,
and with his movies like that too,
right?
There's movies about really important subjects that are terrible movies.
Like how many
caused me to think that if it's are really,
really important subject,
it probably as a terrible movie most likely.
Why do I think that?
Well,
there's no way to really get an important subject and boil it down to two hours.
Oh,
I didn't think of that.
You know,
can be two hours
and employee.
You're right,
Jack.
Yeah,
I mean,
especially like one thing that drives me crazy is when they take liberties with
someone's biography,
like if they would do a biography on someone's life and they change things
around or add things to it for theatrical flair.
She the queen movie.
No,
I did not see it yet.
I haven't seen it either.
I heard it's very good though.
You heard it's very good.
Did you ask the person who told you that why it's good?
Um,
yes.
Yes.
And what did they share?
They said the,
first of all,
the guy who plays Freddie Mercury apparently is brilliant in it.
And it's head they seen originally had they seen Freddie lives?
No,
not live.
I saw Freddy live at the forum.
I was in the maybe 20th row six in when Bohemian rhapsody had just come out.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah,
I saw him in is absolutely.
That is major,
major prime there.
So I'm very curious as to,
well stage is one thing,
but
what Freddie was and what he brought was way more than what you saw on stage.
Yeah.
Very La.
What was he bringing?
Well,
his sensibilities in terms of music weren't just three chords in an attitude and
they'll fall for that shit either.
If Keith ever sits here and tries,
that shit is all raw again and now you just named three three goals in an etude.
Yeah.
And you need to know the inversions of each one.
All seven modal nut.
Fuck you Keith.
Because he does know all those and the trick tunings and whatever.
Yeah.
Um,
Freddy brought a whole wealth of listening to different kinds of music,
whether it was orchestral big band bistro than me done it then.
That's bestrode uh,
uh,
what do you call it?
Music,
music,
that small,
uh,
something you might hear in a coffee shop in France.
Well,
his music was so different.
His singing was so different than anything else from his era.
But you listen to,
we are the champions.
He didn't try to sing black.
Okay.
Sang Freddie Mercury.
We Sang European nonblack what?
We're very used to even in country.
I had a very famous black producer,
African American producer,
say to me,
David Lee,
do you know what it means to be a black man in the United States today?
I see.
Every time I step up to the mic,
I try.
That's what I grew up with,
trying to sound like meltdown,
trying to sound like Wilson Pickett.
Try to sound like an on and on that,
that you know,
that voter block had such an impact on music,
much less the overall culture and comedy.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
if I had to vote for Bingo,
greatest all time,
comedian,
it'd be prior.
The greatest of all time I would,
I would have to say it's,
he's in the running.
I mean,
if it's not him,
I don't know who it is.
I'll agree with you that there's so many,
some,
I mean you look at African American standup comedians and the contribution in
terms of like the overall numbers of the top 10 a giant chunk of them were
black,
a giant Chunk Chappelle,
Chris Rock,
definitely prior.
That guy's,
that guy's forget about Bernie Mac,
Bernie Mac with God damn genius.
You know,
a lot of people don't know about Robin Harris.
Robin Harris has such huge influence to people in the nineties the eighties and
the nineties when he died,
he died.
I think in the early nineties
you're illuminating for the audience,
but here you're preaching to the already convinced judge.
I think it's because of the,
I grew up with comedy records.
Yeah.
Okay.
Red Fox.
And if you're,
you can still hear red doing on the classic comedy channel on Sirius Xm and his
shit is still funny.
It's still good and read.
Let's revisit,
is it the delivery system?
It's everything or the thing,
because you can't sell it.
I started imitating Red Fox when I was probably 12 years old.
That is the lead.
It wasn't walks in,
right?
Yeah.
I should do it.
And you know,
I mean,
Bill Cosby Cosby was obviously a horrible person in retrospect,
but his art form is,
his artwork was amazing.
I mean,
I listen to comedy records.
You memorized word for word,
you memorized Richard Pryor,
you're memorized Red Fox,
you memorize bill Cosby and you memorized Rodney Dangerfield.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
This,
those are the four horsemen.
And if when you run out of conversation at a beer soak,
frat party,
highschool,
whatever,
which is in about two sentences,
you see,
you either quote your favorite movies.
Yeah.
That's how you would converse as guys,
you know,
hey,
let's see where it fucking blows them away.
Fucking a flood.
And we express ourselves or you go,
you start it.
You know,
I can't get no respect.
Yeah.
And,
and doctor told me,
I have to run it.
I even tried this with the staff and said,
David,
how you doing?
Yeah,
man on doctor told me I had to run a 10 a mile a day and then call them on 10
days later.
And while I'm calling you,
I'm 10 miles away.
Rodney Dangerfield.
Okay.
You learned comedy records and you sat around the record player and learned it.
I don't think people do that and no,
no.
That was a thing man.
When I was a kid,
we used to listen to Cheech and Chong.
Big Bamboo would all sit around and listen to the record.
Yeah,
man.
And that was a different one too because they weren't even doing stand up David.
That was a completely unique thing.
They were doing sketch comedy on a record.
It's interesting that pot culture,
which is the international now.
Okay.
Um,
started with an agent and a Hispanic.
Yeah,
they fucking were the kings of it.
Age.
You can again,
sideburns and when it was the old bottoms,
we make fun.
Yeah.
But everybody on earth knows Cheech and Chong.
How many decades later?
How many decades?
I went rock climbing as far away as humanly possible from anything ever made by
God,
man or others please called Arapaho ease.
It's about four hours north of Melbourne out in the middle of nowhere.
Big San drip castles.
You can dial it up and fire rapidly.
And we had a couple of campers like trucks that we parked and we put up a tarp
in the middle and Campfire and whatever.
And uh,
I had a little,
a little television screen and uh,
we plugged that into the car battery.
Okay.
And you know,
I went to the other camp sites because we fucked
up not broad enough,
whatever it was,
water,
food or whatever answer appellees wow.
You know,
I went to the different camp sites and invited everybody,
you know,
hey man,
can I borrow this?
And you guys got any oatmeal or anything like this?
And then yeah,
we were going to be watching Cheech and Chong over under the far edge over
there.
You'll see us,
you'll heal it and come on over and join us from all over the world.
You've got guys from Thailand,
you got girls from England.
Is everybody knew Cheech and Chong.
It was the great leveler or all right.
And when he sat there in subzero temperatures,
swaddled and sleeping bags laughing in seven languages,
she,
John,
look,
you don't even need subtitles.
Yeah,
you don't need to read the movie.
They're back together doing it again,
which is amazing.
And they had to get those guys in here.
As long as they're talking to each other,
they'll make sure.
Are they actually talking to each other or has this gone?
Eddie and Dave,
Eddie and day for a while.
It definitely when Eddie and day for a while,
but they're back.
Yeah,
they're back together.
Well,
they were touring quite a bit.
I think success brought them back together again.
They realize like,
oh,
everybody wants to see Cheech and Chong.
Everybody doesn't really want to see Chung or Cheech.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
not that everybody doesn't want to see them,
but that the numbers are so different.
The numbers of people that,
I mean,
Tommy Chong,
very beloved guy,
but the together,
they're,
they're exponentially more powerful.
It's the Everly brothers.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
It's a,
but the culture changed a man of his times.
Sometimes the times changes and yes,
how the time's now represent that which they,
you know,
pre,
I mean those guys were whatever.
They were doing something that was illegal.
This is illegal comedy.
There was a legal subject matter today in Studio Shitty.
You could spend a 10 day vacation if you came from somewhere and just worked
from the Sushi bar to the dispensary on Studio City.
There's a space,
it's about two miles long.
You could spend 10 days,
come visit us from Japan,
stay at the Marriott all the way near a whatever it is universal and you can on
just work from Sushi bar to dispatch.
Reefers Sushi bar to dispatch dispatcher.
They're touring.
Look at that up on the screen.
There's a whole schedule and it,
where are they working?
I can't read it.
It says there in Richmond,
BC at the river rock casino in Vancouver at the hard rock South Lake Tahoe.
There's a bunch of places.
San Juan,
Puerto Rico in the house.
What's the average age of comics today?
The best ones are in their forties and 50s,
it seems like right now.
Really?
Yeah.
Between Chris Rock,
Dave Chappelle.
Oh,
you're right.
Okay.
[inaudible] um,
yeah,
uh,
the best guy,
Joey Diaz,
all the best guys who are in their 50.
[inaudible]
cause it does change when you think like,
um,
I don't know.
There's a lot of gangster movies on Netflix,
right?
Yeah.
And when it's that,
then the fellows are older,
they're wearing Tuxedos,
you know,
they're in nightclubs,
like Zeros,
kind of a,
yeah,
the 21 club and then that changed to a comedy cellar and you know,
something like that.
Today it's also about productivity.
Like you,
you have to be able to put out material.
And uh,
because most of us are doing Netflix specials now and most of us seem to be on a
schedule of doing one every couple of years.
So you have to be able to turn over an hour every couple of years and then take
that hour and hammer that motherfucker down to a Samurai sword,
excuse me,
a Katana Polish that hammer it down,
Polish that blade.
You have to have it.
And then you have to know when to release it,
which is one of the things that I asked,
like how do you know when you're writing a song like running with the devil?
How do you know when it's done?
Because with a bit you kind of don't know because you do it differently all the
time.
You fuck around with it on stage and you know I'm a tall long does it take to do
an hour?
It just assassinate changes.
It changes.
There's no real one thing I like.
Sometimes I've come up with a new hour and like like four or five months and
sometimes it's taken me a whole year.
It's,
it's really,
it's really different every time depending upon how much effort I put into it.
And also depending upon how lucky I get with subjects,
like sometimes there's a subject,
it's just rich.
Almost like a,
you hit a gold mine and like you hit a ball that he hit that in mind.
You're like,
ah,
there's so much here.
And there's so many.
Also branching off little rivers from this mine,
this one initial mind.
So there's,
there's that.
You never know.
It's,
it's,
it's hard to tell.
Fascinating.
I wouldn't mess around with it.
It moves and changes.
I do it differently all the time.
You know,
I'm,
I'm a giant fan of Leonard Skinner and one of the things that I always thought
was crazy about Skinner was there riffs when they would do guitar riffs,
it was the same riff.
They wouldn't,
when they would do a solo there,
Solos were like orchestrated,
like they don't get enough credit for bringing dynamic musical artists as well
as these southern dudes that were just drinking and singing about whiskey and
getting away from women like they're fat,
ugly dudes.
And most of their songs about getting away from women.
Like,
I gotta go,
I gotta be free.
I'm moving on.
Call me the breeze.
It was so like,
I gotta get the fuck Outta here before he locked me down.
That was a big part of their music.
But when you see like,
um,
like some of their,
uh,
like free bird,
that free bird solo,
that gestalt,
which is one of the greatest solos in the history of all music.
There's some specific reasons for this.
Okay.
One of the more specific reasons is you had to build,
it has a beginning,
a middle,
a crescendo,
and then their,
their specific names to,
um,
when we moved to more channels in recording,
when the Leonard Skinner recorded all their early stuff as eight track and then
you had to double up or early van Halen,
same thing.
You had to compile your tracks or whatever.
Um,
you had to really walk in with your solo
written okay.
And play and you would work it until it really had a thing and crescendos.
Yeah.
Okay.
Once there were many tracks,
guys would come in and just wing it and go,
okay,
let's try one blue.
Okay,
great.
That's fine.
Let's do it again.
Track too.
And they just make it up as they go.
Okay.
And then when it's time to mix,
they'll put a little of track two and a little of track six and start moving
those channels in a way that you would never think to play the guitar.
For example,
ed started doing that on a couple of tracks,
right?
Original Solos running with the devil.
Did it.
It,
it,
it did,
it did it.
Okay.
These are thematic solos.
Most Beetle Solas,
the matic you follow?
Listen to the solo in,
ain't talking about that
[inaudible]
these are thematic solos.
When he started going like this,
he'd record six different versions of the souls.
Okay.
And then just started move the channel.
Like here,
turn this one on,
turn this one off,
turn this 100 and then he'd have to go learn the solo.
Wow.
So he'll see his hand move from down here to up here and down there.
It became a gymnastic effort,
more elbow and shoulder to get his hand from the far end of the fret board all
the way up to the pickup and back to duplicate that Wabisabi wow approach to
making solos.
So it was a very oblique or unique kind of way of creating a solo.
It was utilizing the digital,
digital future,
multi tracking and a improvising.
And we fall as opposed to,
I'm going to sit down and I'm going to just,
I'm going to create something like a book.
Here's the beginning,
here's the scene here.
The character's,
here's the conflict.
Instead,
it's let's just mix that all up together in interesting ways.
It literary Burroughs came up with bill Burroughs many,
many years ago.
Came up with the idea of writing a book than clipping the pages into pieces,
putting them all in a hat and pull the pieces out one by one.
This is piece number one.
This is piece number two,
page number three.
And that's the way you actually remember a story.
Huh?
I don't get that.
Okay.
You remember a wedding?
Yes.
You don't remember in sequence,
right?
We had a batch party,
then I got measured for the tissue,
then I went here.
You remember Badge Party,
then putting the ring.
Then I was throwing up back behind the
Oh then then there was a car and it's,
it's,
it doesn't come in sequential order.
Right.
Okay.
So it's another way of kind of a crafty way of writing an essay.
Um,
perhaps a bit difficult to digest,
but movies are made that way.
Now.
Terentino's starts in the middle,
right?
We're used to it.
Yeah.
He always,
James Bond always starts in the middle of a chase.
Mm.
Door flies open.
Well these guys are,
why is he catch you off guard?
He's running across the top of a train because they started as opposed to here's
the field horse walks onto the field.
I see the cabin,
what I'm getting from this when in regards to his song making in particular the
way Eddie and you did it was there's no shortcuts,
you know,
and the fact that first of all,
you know he's one of the great masters,
right?
Eddie van Halen is one of the great masters.
If you have mean a hundred of the greatest guitar artists of all time and the
history of the human race,
he's in that group.
But we certainly made a contribution commensurate with that.
Yeah,
100% so you have to have that,
but then there's also no shortcuts.
Even when you're a great master.
No,
there's no shortcuts.
No.
You will have to sharpen and sharpen.
And Shar you described sharpening his sword.
I visited a foundry where they make Sorge north of Tokyo.
How was that?
Well,
how does that work?
Is in the,
his work goes into museums.
That is one of the things that I really want to do.
The found my bunk school foundry for guys with hammers,
super sweaty,
hot,
like things like visiting the 16 hundreds.
Okay.
That's not who sharpens and polishes the sword.
That's my other friend who's 55 years old,
lives in a suburb of Tokyo.
That's all he does for a living.
So they take the first sword to him and then he sharpens it.
Yes.
Ah,
Kay.
And he's the one who makes it get that chrome finish.
So the man who forges it does not sharpen it.
Correct.
Different specialty.
Is that always been the case?
Yes.
And insured pot soared.
Polisher does the sharpening and that's a specialty requires shirt and stones
from different parts of Japan.
You don't use wheels,
you use the old stones for the mountains,
et Cetera.
Use water from a wooden book.
Hmm.
You Rub it with your hands.
He's 55 years old.
This is all he does for a living museums from around the world.
Is there a video of this?
Oh yeah.
What's the gentleman's name?
We'll find it.
I'm stalling for a sec.
Uh,
he lives in a very little apartment and he's got two gun safes like you would
use,
you know,
like liberty gun safes and museums from all over the world.
Send Him Sorge Oh,
here he goes.
Okay.
That become a rusty humidity there.
Ah,
what does that,
okay,
this is a pants that's page and he's going to be using,
that's what they use to laminate by putting paste on that sword.
Parts of it will cool differently anyways.
Uh,
so that sharpened has shored takes for ever.
That's what makes your patterns Ah,
so they do it.
It's so you want that edge,
a little different of hardness than you want the rest of the sword you clad.
And what is that sharp feasting on it?
What was that stuff?
It's made of ash and it's made of a
uh,
or,
wow.
And so when it heats up is that when it becomes a part of the sword?
Wow,
he's going to laminate that.
Okay.
This is wild.
Oh,
they got scientists look at this motherfucker with his lab coat.
He's examining,
you're going to ruin it.
Get him out of there.
At that scientist from a shirt and Candice steal Tom Mahogany.
Okay.
And when you do the little padding like dad,
that's ash.
So he's putting little pieces of ash on and on purchase stone.
Ah.
Does that challenge going to sharpen that?
Oh,
you'll spend hundreds of hours doing that on a sword,
which is why they cost so much.
There are many different kinds of of stones that they'll use a different parts
of the sword.
Can you dig the point that the top gets a different kind of stone in the middle
of the sword Cetera?
It's amazing like Japanese culture and especially when you look into the Ancient
Samurai culture,
like a book of five rings is one of my greatest all time books.
I've read it dozens of times in my life.
But to put yourself in the mindset of someone with such a singular vision to,
to great,
to become a Great Samurai,
he needed to become a great artist,
a great poet.
He needed to be good at carpentry.
He needed to be good at calligraphy.
He needed to have all these different skills.
No,
just like your kids shout.
Yeah.
He kids got to take chess lessons or go or go go lessons.
Okay.
Uh,
they got to learn to paint and draw.
Yeah.
You got to learn some martial arts.
Yeah,
multiple languages.
This is a liberal arts education is seen through the eyes of somebody in the 15
hundreds
it's just,
I'm so fascinated with Japanese countries.
So many things came from that one.
Small Island,
I mean you look into in terms of like martial arts contributions,
I mean it is probably the,
there's a bunch of contributors,
Brazilian Jujitsu and Chinese Kung Fu and western boxing,
but God damn,
you look at the contributions of Japan.
I mean overwhelming,
just overwhelming between judo and Jujitsu and so many different martial arts,
karate,
this,
so many different styles that were perfected in this one small place.
Okay.
Jen Island,
I agree with you and that lends itself towards grilling down burrowing in newly
digging in.
Yeah.
You follow.
If somebody is going
to make a sword,
it takes six different people to make one sword.
The person who makes the handle is not the person who wraps the handle.
The person who makes the sword is not the one who sharpens it.
The collar,
the furniture on the sword,
the peg that holds it in that gold's collar,
that's a different person.
And the person who makes the scabbard for the sword,
is it different person?
You want me to keep going?
Oh yes.
I mean,
what's an age of specialization?
Yeah.
Started for them many,
many decades ago.
The idea of,
uh,
I'm one man and I'll build everything in the cabin alone in the wilderness.
Great movie comes from 19 six.
She's is the fellow who builds the cabin and uses handmade tools to do it up in
the woods.
Right?
I'll dig the,
well,
I'll plant the potatoes.
I'll build the house owl,
create the hearth.
I'll fish the fish,
I'll hunt the elk,
et cetera.
And the Japanese perhaps,
you know,
as well as other neighborhoods shed.
I'm just going to specialize in ALC.
Mm.
Yeah.
And somebody else said,
uh,
um,
I just like to cook if that's okay.
Yeah.
Somebody else said,
I'm not even going to cook it.
I'm going to eat it raw.
Have you had,
have you ever fucked around with archery?
Oh,
a million years ago,
you know,
with scouts,
whatever.
But uh,
that seems like something that'd be right up your alley.
That's a,
it's a,
an act of doing it without doing.
Yes.
It is a mind cleansing thing too.
I think you'd be perfect for you.
This is what I saw.
You have a virtual reality range out there.
Oh,
wait a minute.
All right officer,
I confess it's all coming back.
I see.
I saw you on TV.
A filling.
The frigerator are getting ready to fill the frigerator with a bow and Arrow
hours.
Um,
so tell me about this.
I bow hunt.
Actually eat.
Yeah,
right.
Oh,
100%.
Tell us.
Most of what I eat is elk meat or,
or deer meat.
Yeah,
that's the,
if you look at my diet on paper,
it's probably 60% elk.
When did you begin this?
Uh,
2012 was the first hunting trip I went on.
My good friend Steve Rinella took me on a trip on his television show meat
eater.
And then,
uh,
I became obsessed.
Well I was,
I was trying to figure out what I was doing because I had seen a bunch of
factory farming videos and I was like,
okay,
I'm either going to become a vegetarian or I'm going to become a hunter.
Like,
uh,
this is,
I follow that and be a part of this.
I follow then.
So I became a hunter and a,
first of all,
the nutrition that you get from wild games,
she a difference.
Feel the difference.
Yeah.
Everybody does.
I give it to a friend.
He just feel better.
It just feels amazing.
Yeah.
It's so nutrient dance since red and rich.
And so why you're eating an athlete and you're eating a wild athlete that's
running away from wolves and mountain lions.
I mean,
it's just a different thing than a cow that's like locked up in a cage or a pig
that's locked up in a stall.
It makes stellar since and they live a free life.
It's a wild animal.
They,
there's no one telling them what to do or where to go,
and you gotta be able to sneak it up in on them on the right wind with the right
conditions,
and make sure you get a shot off on them.
Yeah,
I love it.
How often you go out?
A couple times a year,
usually two or three times a year.
All the way.
Yeah.
If three commercial freezers in the back,
I'll show you after we're done.
I have a three elk.
There were two elk rather than her parsed up and to elk and two axis deer and
those freezers.
Yeah,
each ELC has several hundred pounds of meat,
you know,
and then I'd give a lot of it to my friends.
A good portion of my friends,
they always get a little packages of elk for me.
Elk Sausage and elk roasts and all these different things.
I'm always giving people recipes,
showing them how to eat it,
me how to cook it.
Citrus thing,
that's the most modern way is the,
is the classic.
I eat what I call rabbit food.
It's the Cracko Diet,
like a crocodile Berge foliage.
D One credit hour says the other ones you have for breakfast,
the chicken,
anything that is it sitting in?
We
what'd,
what'd you have fish when you catch it in seaweed,
but a,
that seems to serve me the Brady Diet.
Everybody's talking about the Tom Brady Diet.
What does he do?
Well,
we call it eating,
eating,
eating clean.
Who's not eating any processed flies?
Not eating any white bread.
He,
she,
nope.
Meal and clean proteins,
you know,
know fried stuff.
And he's in his forties so it's crazy.
Yeah,
he's,
he's a,
is he a miracle?
Is something special on when you look at his body,
he looks like a guy at the beach,
like a regular guy.
He doesn't look like a super athlete.
One of the greatest football players of all time.
Are we seeing something?
Because between him and Alex Honnold and there are a couple of others,
stellar,
like,
Whoa,
are we starting to see a trend because of better nutrition and better training
and cross trainings?
And there's so many factors.
When you deal with football,
there's so many fewer,
bigger,
stronger.
Yeah.
Well,
I think with football,
with with Tom Brady,
I think it's training,
intelligence,
dedication,
obsession,
and then also nutrition,
all those,
all those factors.
But you have to like really be,
and there's no way to be as good as he is without being incredibly immersed in
whatever you're trying to excel at.
There's no way.
And with Alex Honnold,
I mean the guy lives out of his van because he wants to live out of his van
because all he wants to do is just drive around to different mountains and climb
them.
I mean,
that's his thing.
For me,
it was the surfers.
Yeah.
1960s exact
same lifestyle.
They needed to be use a vertical for Kentucky's,
the doors of the useless,
they call themselves some vertical surfer.
That's it.
Yeah,
it's a vertical.
So for me it was,
you know,
we're going to go camp at Santa,
no free,
you know,
which is something that you talked to surfers.
There's something,
there's a weird corny way to put it,
but I haven't talked to all of them obviously,
but a lot of high level surfers like Kelly Slater or let go out,
my good friend Shane Dorian,
they are,
they're spiritual in some strange way.
They're at peace in some strange way.
And I think part of it is because they're constantly on that ocean and I think
the ocean is like a battery.
I think you get energy out of it.
I think it,
it's alive.
It feels alive.
I think it stimulates you in a very unique way.
And with those guys,
they're writing these immense waves,
these,
these creations of nature and gravity and force and mass and water and that Wa
riding them and they're riding a living thing.
There's organisms in it.
It's,
it's filled with salt.
I mean it's,
it charges the body.
It's got a different frequency than the rest of the world.
And these guys,
they seem different.
They have a,
there's a different vibe about them.
I'm more content vibe.
I've always said it's like there's something about beach towns,
like why is everybody by the beach so fucking chill?
Like what is that something crazy?
Music isn't chill,
Jack Johnson is,
but you know what I'm saying?
Classic Surf Music is
Donna.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah.
I guess it's some,
sounds like the waves mimic the way,
the way I perhaps Dick Dale and the Dell Tomes,
we're imitating the way waves made you feel.
Whoa.
No,
no,
no.
And now they're playing what it feels like to sit around the campfire on the
beach,
right?
Yeah.
That kind of shit.
It's kind of a beach tone.
A little bit.
Is it runner's high?
I don't know.
Cause we used to walk into the running stores and you know everybody behind the
counters.
I did attended a gray and it stays with,
that's day that stays with you.
I ride my bicycle everywhere.
I'm on two wheels.
I've successfully replaced the automobile and Pasadena.
Really?
I got to go to the seven 11 I'm on the bicycle.
I got to Pasadena.
Oh yeah.
I want to go to the,
you know,
wherever you get on the bicycle in the rain,
doesn't matter.
Really.
Yeah.
Just you don't drive the car as in Pasadena as infrequently as possible.
Wow.
This,
this is cow.
I cross train as opposed to,
I think we can going to hire coaches.
It's just stay on that bike.
What have you go to dinner somewhere.
Don't laugh.
Okay.
I'll take it to an extreme.
When I'm in New York City,
I have my bike and everything's set up over there and my bicycle and so forth.
Got a little apartment there.
Um,
I saw a scene in doctor know,
careful what you let your kids
see.
It could be for life.
Sean Connery comes out of the ocean and one of those black neoprene wetsuit.
Right,
right.
And he peels it off and he's got a blue Tuxedo on underneath without a drop of
water.
Do I have to finish this?
Yeah,
no.
I got my,
I got my jumpsuits and I got my flight suits and everything like is more than
once I've gone to a club or a dinner,
I give the door guy or the parking guy or the as it John,
that's my bike chained up over there and the corners,
$20 keep an eye on it.
Don't let any pro snap that walk.
And I just stuffed my backpack up under the bike like this.
I do this in the rain.
I do it in the snow.
I do it every once somebody says the rain and go.
Yeah.
Like every kid in Hawaii,
there are no snow days in Hawaii.
It's raining.
Just assume it.
There are no snow days in the Dakotas.
It's snowing.
Yeah,
go to school.
And uh,
I've done this all over the world.
I take my bicycles with me wherever I go.
So when you were in Japan,
he took a bike.
Oh,
I know who all of Tokyo bike.
Like I know the roof of my mouth take you anywhere on those streets.
I know every alleyway.
I know all the ways downtown.
I would routinely make a two hour trip to my art lessons from where I lived all
the way downtown,
each Ebisu and all the way back like that.
When you drive around today as opposed to in the old days before cell phones,
do you notice a difference with people paying attention?
Text moves?
I know that getting off the line could take a week depending on
the light changes and counting on how long it takes is everybody's got to sign
off their phone,
turn off the computer,
do as or whatever.
Um,
by and large,
um,
what I have noticed is that when people are watching you,
they no longer have their hands in their pockets and pretend to be Westlake.
Now you pretend you stare into your cell phone.
That's true.
You've,
oh,
and a fan or somebody who's watching you and said,
are you gonna go like,
that's 1960s now they look today more often than not,
I'm the only guy who's actually present in a place I walk into a coffee shop has
the cell phone.
No,
I walk into a coffee shop or a restaurant or even a club,
which is pretty centrally a social experience and everybody is staring into
their cell phones in different banquettes and different whatever.
I'm more often than not,
I'm the only one who's actually present looking,
seeing,
have you airing,
smelled old with those things.
Have you ever oh sure.
Fucked with them.
And you decided it's not for you.
I'm going to let you know a little secret.
Very digitally literate.
Okay.
I can fly a $6 million helicopter backwards.
Can you really?
Yes,
but it forces people to make eye contact.
You want to talk to me?
You have to sit just like this.
Okay.
And you can't text me cause that's avoidance.
Can't a,
there's a whole lot of off ramps I take out of the program.
What about email?
I don't.
You don't email?
Nope.
Well I'm surrounded by individuals and I know exactly what to ask for and about.
So what do you want to get ahold of you?
They have to go find you.
At no point in my life.
Like as a,
with yourself,
I'm assuming,
am I more than five feet away from somebody with a cell phone?
Uh,
I was laughing.
It's like James Bond or some secret agent shit.
We're even Miguel,
the Gardner has a smartphone.
Everyone has one.
He's going to pull a gun and defend me,
whoever it,
carry them at one point and decide to stop carrying them.
Yes.
And it became a constant,
uh,
as show people.
We are targets,
targets for love,
targets for greed,
targets for proximity,
it's Cetera.
And uh,
it became a constant interruption,
became a constant sheet in an effort to find my way to where Shane Dorian is.
I want to be out on that wave.
Man.
I want calm.
I want to live in New York City.
I want to live in the middle of the noise and the clamor and I want to be able
to keep my heart rate down.
I want to be able to keep my waist down.
You dig.
And uh,
I found myself constantly having to answer that phone and having to deal with,
hey man,
how are you?
Just what cut to the crash.
And uh,
getting texted is avoidance.
Yeah.
Nine and a half times out of 10 it's just somebody who didn't really want to
talk on the phone.
You hear this?
Well,
I texted you.
I tell you,
you're the only plan Yam landing today.
Yeah.
But at any given time,
the guy driving the car,
the assessment,
even the Gardner has a smartphone and everybody knows you can find me.
Yeah.
And You keep it that way.
But yeah.
So what,
what year was it where he decided to do this?
How long ago?
About four years ago.
Four years ago.
You bought into then you carrying the phone,
doing the whole deal and you went,
I don't want this anymore.
It was constant phone ringing,
constantly having to check in.
Constant of,
uh,
I called you,
how come you didn't call me back?
Rah Rah Rah became a leash.
Yeah.
It also indicates,
you know,
as you start to call over and over and over again,
it's,
it's a like a tracer.
You follow?
Um,
you have stalkers.
Sure.
Got a good one.
No,
no.
Right.
I got stockers.
Yeah,
I got a stock or who makes prank call?
Uh,
I can tell you what time get the work.
I can tell you what time he goes home.
I can tell you if he went to church and then brunch and what time he got home
from that.
I can tell you if you had something to drink the night before and went home and
slept it off the next day.
It's the nature of communications.
Remember tracer bullets worked both ways.
Boy,
you're going to indicate everywhere you are and everything you do and your whole
entire thing of your lives.
Very Orwellian.
Especially with social media,
right half and probably the last thing I want you to know about me is how boring
I am.
Not Kidding.
There's also,
there's a thing of giving into this non human device and integrating it with
your life.
You W W and where people just,
they never leave it alone.
They're constantly on it.
They're checking it with,
you're not even getting anything out of it.
You're just checking it for nothing.
He'd just checking your email,
checking your photos,
checking your Instagram is nothing coming,
nothing positive coming out of it.
It's just like this weird distraction from life.
Used to use the frigerator for that.
Yeah,
that's right.
It's almost the same.
You're so right.
It's like a digital version of opening the refrigerator when you know nothing's
in there.
Grazie that's so true.
It's so true.
It's like boredom
exercise.
Yeah.
It's a habit or ranch for it or reach for it.
Do you have one just in case you have to use it?
I'm giving away all my secrets.
I am constantly in the grid.
Okay.
Um,
one of my closest colleagues that I work with two or three nights a week,
college Smith has written 17 books on how to run Adobe photo shop.
Okay.
We've been working on an art project together for quite some time.
We'll debut that at another time.
Um,
I love the Internet.
I love what the digit future has brought to us.
My only real regret in life is that I didn't have this grown up.
Go look it up.
I should have that tattooed
and signed by my parents.
Yeah,
it's a great time for finding things out.
The information if you want to learn the encyclopedia Britannica was what we had
goes look it up and Canterbury records in case you wanted some music,
which was an hour's bike ride each way.
Okay.
And I can keep going and now you can get music.
Oh my God.
It was just,
it's for somebody like me when,
uh,
I was flavor of the week,
the first time,
know I did all the rock star stuff and one of the first things that I wanted to
do because I'd read that Elton John,
this is,
you would them to close the store,
shop around by yourself and no,
no.
You got to have a security guy of course,
brings a pillowcase.
Ah,
he put the records on a pillowcase with impunity.
Ooh.
Pick your records.
It,
you don't even read the liners.
Yeah.
If you have a good cover,
you're in the camp.
Yeah.
I remember that.
I used to buy records based on how cool the cover looked.
Oh.
Routinely to chance route team lax,
especially double album covers and,
and,
and uh,
I would routinely,
I would shop by weight.
Okay.
I would do that at bookstores too,
as much as we could carry coming out of the bookstores because for example,
um,
I like many different kinds of music.
One of my favorites is danceable Electronica,
uh,
R and B disco.
Anything that has a call it floor.
If it has anything to do with dancing,
it's four.
And there were no floor stations here in the,
in California in the 70s.
You wanted to hear anything that's,
you know,
you had KJLH may be some small am kind of a station,
but you went to New York.
You had,
let me put the headphones on.
I could do the voice.
This is puggle.
There'll be you,
Katie,
you shuttled traffic
this time.
Bay,
Ebay.
We're missing djs.
Sorry.
That's something that's missing from our culture,
the comet and Bob and Bob and with the best bet for the boss.
Beat at the top of the pops.
Managed gold.
I'm diamond Dave.
No time to waste to making the taste baby shut up.
Time to play the record.
Big Wolf,
man Jack,
those guys are gone.
That,
that's like a missing segment of our culture.
I was in pass and Dena listening for the first FM radio underground station,
which was KPPC.
It was metro media,
I believe it was channel five.
Tell me if this gets too boring.
Um,
here's the history of it is during the Cold War,
right around 1965 66 it became a legal imperative that all radio stations,
regular ones had to operate an FM band station.
Fm had been around since the 1930s my uncle man,
he remembered it.
Okay.
But it never got used.
It was am radio
KFW be channel 98 and it was like the mighty 10 90,
you know.
Okay.
That kind of screaming Dj kind of thing.
Why?
Because you know,
in case there's an a national emergency,
you are not allowed to take your normal programming though from Kfw WB and put
it on your sister station on FM had to be different programming.
Hmm,
okay.
You can't just dominate FM because you've got the advertisers,
your channel five get a lot of advertisers.
You got Earl Scheib car paint there,
right?
You have rinse.
So you've got,
uh,
chasing Sandborne coffee,
you're going to squeeze me,
right,
right.
You're not allowed to have the same programming and channel five,
they operate a KPP sheet,
which is a one oh six point shopping today.
It's k rock or whatever in it.
Like when I was six right in there and uh,
uh,
they brought in literally all these FM stations.
She,
you know,
the,
the is,
you know,
all said well,
uh,
my nephew,
he's,
he loves that rock stuff.
You know,
he's,
he's got a lot of records.
Maybe he'll be a DJ kind of thing or who,
who would be a DJ for this kind of stuff?
I don't know.
Who's a non screamer?
The jazz guys.
Yeah.
Okay.
They brought in big daddy,
Tom Donahue and his wife Rachel.
And they came in and they start broadcasting on KPPC and Tom was a jazz DJ and
he would talk just kind of like this and Da,
okay,
we got a new quicksilver here.
Can't wait till it comes out and stereo.
Take a listen now to first side see in a few.
Yeah.
And we would practice that.
There's an art to that.
Oh yeah.
There's an art to preparing you for a new song.
Yeah.
Okay.
Got a brand new wouldn't here.
Yeah.
He use development hand like Djs,
you know,
like sweat,
jazz,
jazz guys.
Back then a lot of them were uh,
doing things that
cause you to slow down,
you know what I mean?
And we started doing those things too.
Lula gauge here,
little strength.
A patient's Joe knows about me,
I do right after that.
And then it would set you up for the music.
You'd actually enjoy the music a little bit more because of that guy.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
We get into the hands too.
Okay.
Here's a little something.
You work kind of Kook,
inspiring that if streaming services are smart,
they would bring that shit back.
They'd find someone you know,
because like streaming services are the new radio,
right?
I mean that's where a lot of people get their music.
The grade I'm talking about like Pandora.
Yeah.
All those things.
That's sort of what Apple's pitch was.
They have a whole radio section on apple music and they have beaches.
Yeah,
they have shows and well the DJ is running on both.
but like as a sport judge,
what is it in the natural,
okay,
great movie,
Bro.
Duvall devolves a writer,
a writer,
and they get into a little bit of an argument.
He says,
you don't play baseball.
yeah,
but on a good day I can make it look a little bit more interesting and make it a
little more exciting to help you see what she tells me.
You understand what?
Paraphrase?
Sure.
That's what I do with the exact,
that's an art form that implicates everything.
Drama,
pay,
throws whole Larry.
It all in one paragraph.
I've watched you go from zoo.
Yeah.
That's how I can pull up in a channel seamlessly.
I grew up with the greats.
Scully.
Co-Sale Sal,
tell me,
so tell me Holly.
So cash is please.
It's all the cash it out.
Okay.
And we would imitate that for,
you know,
trying to get that kind of an eloquent sal,
you know.
Um,
but you have djs,
they're not really djs.
They are representatives of a lifestyle.
For example,
I'm going into Dj voice cause I got the headphones.
This is why I don't wear the headphones cause come to aware.
Yeah,
it's sun goes down.
I haven't been to sleep since the late eighties.
Um,
what was I talking about?
I started riffing there.
Djs,
djs now aren't really Dj's.
When you listen,
for example is Sirius Xm.
You have for example,
the country artist.
Sure.
Okay.
And it's no shoes,
radio and you know,
it's um,
he's not a humorist.
Okay.
He's not even an interlocutor he and behold.
And so it came to pass like in Greek tragedy.
And so it came to pass that the sun came in,
the war was won.
He's not that.
It's Kenny Chesney going.
And I say it with respect,
you know,
hi,
this is Kenny.
And I was just walking down here in Panama City and my phone went dead.
No,
I walked inside and I asked as Goodfellas rag here at the Joe Rogan Barbecue,
fire it up.
If I could just sort of charge it up.
And they said,
hell yeah.
So I'll just want him to tell you y'all come down road mark Cuban and she can
always find is right here on no shoes radio.
Oh,
so there's something,
it's not really follow.
It's not announced.
He was,
he's kind of being,
um,
Tom Petty.
He was a coke and spirit or you know,
like,
hey man,
I'm down here in the basement,
me and I'm listening to some recommendation and we'll burn.
It's fire up the bong.
Check this out.
This is fucking tasty.
This is it.
It's an important,
I had friends like that.
They could choose the music too.
Was the other thing about Tj,
they would choose the music.
I don't know.
A taste maker.
FM radio.
Yeah.
Yes.
You Bet.
And yeah,
that makes a big difference.
I did not think about as listen to WBCN in Boston.
It was a like 1980s and uh,
they wanted to play Michael Jackson.
And the guy said,
listen,
I know this isn't rock is WBCN was the rock a boss to sure.
But they're like,
look,
I know this isn't rock,
but damn,
this is good music.
And they played Billie Jean.
I remember thinking,
Wow,
what a bold choice to watch a bold choice in a certain sense.
Okay.
And the Shurtan Shank is that after Awhile FM radio became very codified.
You know,
just like the horse race is somewhere in the mid seventies,
late seventies it became a playlist and the djs no longer pick their own
records.
Program directors picked the records.
Okay.
And it became very specific target demo we want a home in and whatever.
And keep in mind when Howard stern left regular radio,
terrestrial radio for the stratosphere,
I got his job in New York City.
Oh,
that's right.
I was broadcasting in seven different cities.
I forgot you did that.
Okay.
Dallas,
New York,
Philly,
I think I was an and Cetera,
cetera.
And it turns out,
I think what they wanted was a version of Howard Stern.
Okay,
great.
I'll be a third class,
Howard stern or a first class David Lee.
My approach to is very different then his would be,
we're two very different people.
He's talking,
he's a personality.
It's all about interaction.
I see myself as show people,
I'm music first.
Okay.
So the first thing I'm going to pick when we throw a barbecue is not the food or
the guest list,
but what's the music?
Right.
Well,
white people listen to Bob Marley when we're on vacation and when we celebrate
things,
we listened to Kool and the gang,
right?
Right.
And I would play those and the ratings were going up and they were pissing off
management really well.
They said,
we feel that Leonard Skinner to Nickelback are more appropriate for your
audience.
So the ratings were going up and they were upset.
And because you couldn't rein me in.
Okay,
now keep in mine.
I hired cooling the gang open for van Halen tour before last.
You have never seen so many people dancing in one place because that's the sound
of every wedding.
Bar Mitzvah Fromm Bachelor party.
Cause this is ladies night and the fee,
oh,
a water die.
And you got to sing that.
Look at each other as you're driving,
going whoa to God.
What did they say to you before you took the job?
Like what was the,
what was the conversation when you agreed to do it?
What did you think was going to happen as opposed to what did happen?
Well,
what you say and what is real.
Yeah,
that's the problem right now.
I,
we've discussed doing commercials for example,
and I don't feel comfortable doing commercials unless it's something I actually
use,
you know,
like sunglasses or cigarettes
behind that,
you know,
Vermont care bear kind of a thing.
I don't know.
Right.
So it was uncomfortable from the beginning.
I got fired for playing too much ethnic music and uh,
for late night humor too early in the morning.
But that was Howard Stern's hold deals late nine.
Humor.
No it's not.
It's a different kind of humor.
What was your deal as opposed to his,
well,
whenever we brought on porn stars,
I actually knew them.
There were no died.
We'd already gone through the getting to know you phase seasons earlier,
kind of an expect you to do all talk or did they want you to play music as well
as just my sense of humor is different.
Unique as is his and as is yours.
Okay.
You can't eat.
We have old league of imitations in our end of the business in broadcasting.
Okay.
But um,
there no snare drum and high hat nor is there for Howard.
You follow?
He,
he's very,
again,
I start with the music.
I start with the ambiance and if humor arises or personalities arise or we have
guests,
great.
If we don't,
that's fine too.
Um,
uh,
and I think they expected other,
what I showed up with was it,
it also ranged,
uh,
it wasn't always funny.
Mm.
Okay.
Do you think that it was just maybe something you would have excelled at if they
had different expectations?
Like instead of following Howard stern it,
they just did this David Lee Ross,
you bet.
Do you think you'd still be doing it?
Uh,
yes.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Their expectations was the funny,
the funny interview.
The guests have pop culture,
funny guests and the subject matter.
Just as we've touched on subjects here that are hilarious and subjects that are
pretty dense.
Yeah,
it was,
I call it,
you're just going to detonate halfway down the turnpike.
Oh,
that's what he fucking meant.
It's not stuff that's going to go away real quick.
Do you,
have you thought about doing that now?
Like what if apple came to you or one of these streaming services came to you
and wanting to do something like that?
They always arrive with expectations
and the expectations.
Just as we discussed,
three phases of Anna Nicole Smith and Elvis.
Which Dave are you referring to?
Well,
I just think it just with someone like you.
I mean I'm not a program director,
but if I was,
I
would say just let him be him.
Just figure it out.
Just let it,
give it time to grow.
That's what people don't do.
The metal,
the metal,
they are like,
you're going to do,
I look from what I know of you,
you're going to do your best at everything.
Everything you do,
you're going to do your best.
If I was going to hire you,
that's what I would say.
Everybody get the fuck away from him.
He's going to do his best now let them hire who he wants to hire and do what he
wants to do and put what he wants to put on and let him figure it out.
But you hired David Lee Roth,
he didn't hire Mike Fitzgerald and,
and,
and Ken Buchanan,
whatever the fuck the other people are that work in the office.
It also wants to just in the soup.
No,
you hired David Lee Roth.
Let David Lee Roth Be David Lee Roth and let him find his legs.
That's a difficult entity because it comes with a lot of history.
Yeah.
You know,
and then the people will start,
folks will start conducting.
Wow,
you gotta play this.
You got a plate.
And it has very specific expectation usually.
However,
in this age there's a lot,
a lot of freedoms.
There's a lot of,
uh,
you know,
what you're discussing is something that I think about occasional.
So it seems like something you'd be open to nail home,
get you a job.
Just from this particular interview,
I would be very open to it.
Um,
I,
uh,
you know,
they've approached me before to talk about it.
Um,
my interest in music is diverse,
but it's energized.
Switched on.
Henry Rollins of course,
does his own radio show and he picks his own pelly list.
It's like one of the last few things that a person like him who is able to do
like that,
and he does it once he once a week.
Right.
Does it,
and he's going one night a week.
He does and he loves it.
I mean,
something else that people have approached me for is a writing a column.
Some of the good magazines have approached me,
big ones about becoming a writer and interesting to you.
You Bet.
Yeah.
It seems like it would be,
you bet it's a,
it's a different,
uh,
sound when we,
right.
Yeah,
no,
it's a,
it's in a bit of a different voice.
It's,
um,
my sense of humor comes out of it a little bit more in terms of darkness.
I remember reading an article in New York magazine's far bags,
1968 I don't remember the elements of the fellow was the theater critic for New
York magazine and the title was in defense of booing.
Huh.
Interesting.
Is Why do we always ask to tolerate clapping,
especially for shitty performances.
There's the clapper who claps because they're part of the gang and there's the
clapper yells,
Bravo.
So that they exist.
I am heard.
And he talks about how,
you know,
he gets thrown out of an opera for booing and everybody knew a theater critic
for 36 years.
Ah,
at New York magazine.
Wow.
And it always a permit booing and I support that.
America stands alone.
Well that Kinda sneak Shin,
not just a zip as a form of negative targeting.
Okay.
But as a form of elevating,
you dig,
you don't go to the golf swing guy put on all the electrodes,
they do the slow motion things or you can go your gray Joe.
No,
he wants to go see your wrist.
Right,
right.
So what you're doing with the elbow and making them mistake.
Exactly.
He's there to identify the flaw,
right?
If there's no flaws,
there's no booing.
You know,
a lot of folks are going to go,
Jesus,
man,
you,
you concentrate on the negative.
I love booing as much as going,
Yay.
In fact,
I can think of certain heavy metal records that we could discuss on the airplane
from La to New York.
That's five hour flight.
And I could discuss though,
record endlessly as long as we're going,
boo.
If we're discussing what's wrong with it,
you can go for five hours.
What's great about it?
How long are you going to sustain that 20 minutes.
Ah,
it's really smart
and smart.
The
criticism,
you know,
identifying the flies,
not negative,
right?
I'm having a bell over here.
Your days.
It's sort of a good example.
As Ed Wood's monster movies,
you see the string,
you see the smoke,
you see the flying saucer,
it looks fake.
That's a,
that you feel smugly superior.
You look at that thing that's,
you know,
it's a form of booing.
Yeah.
You know,
now today,
if it was people weren't doing that,
you wouldn't have black panther.
You wouldn't have spider man.
You wouldn't have Avengers and all the amazing special effects and CGI and
everything because it's high expectations.
It's just somebody going,
I see the string.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Joe.
All right.
Let me invent computers and I'll get back to you.
David Lee Roth.
We just did three hours.
He believed that time flies when you don't know what you'd do with Joe.
You know what you're doing.
Sly Son of a bitch.
Doing nothing means a lot to me.
Did we really nail three hours?
Really did tell people one more time about your product line and where,
what website it is the original and please say it that Way Inc.
The original in the original,
not the metric enough ink.
The original.
She's pretty.
That's really it.
Go get a pretty good set shit.
We make it for everybody who's got ink,
anybody who's got tattoos and stuff.
Virtually everything that you're going to use in boot wire,
the bathroom,
anything here putting the locker,
but especially that brightener man,
that stuff's the shit dad that will read bome no more rubbing it with your
finger,
etc. And we've got a whole product line coming in.
Laughter.
When is the
name of the company today?
I'm going to order a bunch of shit so you don't have to order it.
We'll have it delivered.
I'm going to order just because I love you.
God bless David Lee Roth.
You're a bad motherfucker coming,
Joe.
That's a very special belt to wear.
Thank you,
sir.
David Lee Roth,
ladies and gentlemen.
Goodnight.